at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by teeter I am so thrilled to have
connected with these guys because I've
used teeter products for many many years
I've traveled around the country and the
world with Teeter products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from
one of their inversion tables and we're
gonna talk more about all of that one of
my rituals is hanging and I should say
not really that it's a maintenance and
performance program I hang not just in
the morning potentially but particularly
after a day of bearing weight whether
that includes weight training in Jersey
Greg rec world record holder insists on
this type of inversion therapy after
training or just wearing heavy backpack
around a few minutes goes a long way
towards better sleep in my case less
back pain neck pain leg pain it's not a
panacea obviously but inversion therapy
which uses gravity in your own
bodyweight to decompress the spine and
relieve pressure on the discs and
surrounding nerves seems to help with a
whole slew of conditions and just as a
general maintenance program it's one of
my favorite things to do so what to say
about that Teeter why Teeter Teeter is
the best known name in inversion table
since 1981 more than three million
people have put their trust in Teeter
Teeter is also the only inversion table
brand that has been both safety
certified by Underwriters Laboratories
that's ul for you people in that
industry you will recognize it and
registered with the FDA as a class 1
medical device and they're giving a very
special offer just to you guys my
listeners for a limited time you can get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories which I have a bunch of
again in the room next to me and a free
pair of gravity boots so that you can
invert at home or take the boots with
you to the gym so these gravity boots I
have three
separate pairs of gravity boots bought
with my own money z' in three different
cities that I've had for a very very
long time because I don't want to travel
with them necessarily it look kind of
like ski boots but without the foot
portion and they hook you upside down so
you can take them really anywhere you
want to go to get this deal which is a
savings of over a hundred and forty
eight dollars it's very specific so
maybe it's a hundred and forty nine you
have to go to Teeter dot-com /tu Tim
that's Teeter comm /to MT EE ter you
also see a free shipping a 60 day money
back guarantee and free returns so why
not try it out remember you can only get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots by going to teeter comm forward
slash Tim so if you're thinking yourself
what the hell is this thing he's talking
about I can't even envision it in my
head well take a look at the photos go
to Teeter comm forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by LegalZoom
which more than 2 million Americans have
used to help start their businesses past
guests even such as well WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg now valued at more than a
billion dollars have used Legal Zoom to
help with their business needs
specifically in his case to form his
company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business
the best part is that you won't get
charged by the hour because Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm so they won't be
running the clock up and spinning
circles just to raise your bill instead
they just ask you to pay one low upfront
price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get ala carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter
Timm t IM at checkout capital T
lowercase I am again take a peek
legalzoom.com and enter promo code to
him why hello my darling knitted Mogwai
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
or it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out the
habits routines experiences life lessons
frameworks etc that you can hopefully
apply to your own lives my guest today
is someone I've known for quite a few
years now she's incredible
Aisha Tyler that is a is h80 yle are on
twitter instagram vimeo and beyond she
is an award-winning director actor
comedian best-selling author podcaster
and activist she does just about
everything and if you've enjoyed my
episodes with for instance Brandon
Stanton Debbie Millman or Adam Robinson
among others you will love this one
whether you do creative work want to be
too complex to categorize want to
overcome rejection and be the odds
despite the fears and insecurities we
all have this will have something for
you Aisha voices super spy lana kane on
FX's Emmy award-winning animated comedy
series Archer which one for back-to-back
Television Critics Choice Awards she is
a regular on the hit CBS show Criminal
Minds now in its 13th season for which
she has also directed Aisha continues to
host the CW's hit improv show whose line
is it anyway and she's launching a line
of bottled cocktail she created courage
and stone in summer of 2018 take a
breath sit back that's not all let me
get a little bit more in just to give
you a taste and man this doesn't even
capture a small fraction but here we go
Aisha was a Coast for seven seasons of
CBS's Emmy winning daytime show the talk
which she departed in September 2017 to
focus more on acting and directing she's
also very well remembered for her
character arc on friends where she was
the first african-american to have a
long-standing role on the show her
feature film debut the thriller axis all
caps ax is premiered 2017 and won the
outstanding achievement in feature
filmmaking ward at the 2017 Newport
Beach Film Festival and then had a
theatrical run at Arclight Hollywood
landmark and
I see and Drafthouse in my home of
Austin Texas Alamo Drafthouse so much
fun a San Francisco native where I also
spent a very very long time
I usually graduated from Dartmouth
College with a degree in government and
environmental policy which you might not
have known she is an avid gamer and
passionate advocate and occasional
adversary of the gaming community and
her voice can be heard in video games
like Halo Reach Gears of War 3 and
watchdogs Aishah is a bourbon and hard
rock fan a snowboarder and a sci-fi
obsessive and we cover so much ground in
this episode it's very wide-ranging
she's hilarious and I really really
really enjoyed the twists and turns in
this particular podcast episode so
without further ado please enjoy and you
can find more to enjoy at Aisha Tyler
com of course the namesake of Aisha
Tyler com
Aisha Tyler Aisha welcome to the show
Tim hello thank you I'm super excited to
be here you know this is our this is our
away it's a very long home in a way for
us it is it is and you are partially to
blame slash credit for me having a
podcast in the first place because I
recall when you interviewed me for girl
on guy podcast in San Francisco at my
place and I had so much fun speaking
with you and fielding some fantastic
questions one of which I'm going to
bring up and then we'll backpedal okay
but this was the question will not be
surprising to you I don't think I'm
gonna ask you to bring it up but the the
conversation that we had in part
contributed to me deciding to take a
break from writing books which it
completely burned me out and in turn
helped birth the show so thank you for
helping to send me on this path because
it's become one of the most gratifying
and fascinating things I could possibly
imagine doing so thank you for that it's
so thrilling to hear and really really
gratifying yeah I mean that's it's
amazing I think podcasts are wonderful
and terrible beasts but like really
satisfying even even when they're like
punishingly difficult to manage they're
still so satisfying so I'm really happy
I'm happy that you're enjoying it and
you have we're not going to get into
this right now although we can you have
a book titled self-inflicted wounds
subtitle heartwarming tales of epic
humiliation and can you maybe repeat or
even paraphrase the question that you
would always ask guests on your show oh
absolutely I mean that came that the
name for that book came from this part
of my show self-inflicted wounds which
is somewhat you know tell me a story
about something that's gone wrong in
your life that's your own fault like you
know you can't blame anyone else you
know not your your ex not the bullies in
your school not the man you know you did
it to yourself and it was it was really
a way of initiating a conversation about
risk and failure because I feel like
people see people who are successful and
assume that a part of that's success or
the reason that success is that they
haven't made any mistakes and they
haven't failed that they've got a
charmed life in some way or they figure
some kind of formula out and you know
the the the the most successful people
are people who in not don't just manage
risk but engage in risk and and and
court failure actively and I so I always
love to you know have people listening
see that some of that they admire and
that they think is really accomplishes
really [ __ ] the bed maybe multiple times
because I just think it's it's
instructive I think people don't start
because they're afraid they're gonna
fail and and and there's just no way
around you know that the path to success
is through failure you just can't get
around it so there's so many different
direction
I could go with this and I want to to go
way back as maybe I've like sort of a
montage flashback that we can have as a
visual overlay as you're as you're
saying some of these things
and that is to your dad
and I've in the process of doing
homework read about your dad's favorite
saying or what or question that he would
ask and I was hoping you could you could
explain this or share this with people
who are listening because I think it's
kind of amazing yeah well I was raised
you know my parents divorced when I was
10 and um and my father my parents you
know I was joked that like you know it's
only rich people that can afford to
fight about custody you know I mean poor
people just do whatever they have to do
to like manage and my parents neither
them could really afford two kids and
also neither of them could afford to pay
child support so they just each of them
just took one of us and I was older so I
went with my father and he was like you
know which which one can wash itself and
then that was the one that he took and
he you know my father is the king of the
like the very terse and pointed
motivational speech so I would leave for
school in the morning and we lived in I
grew up in San Francisco and and at one
point we lived upstairs in a Victorian
so I'd go down these very steep stairs
and she'd lean over the railing and he'd
go whose day is it I'd had to say it's
my day and then he'd say what are you
gonna do and I'd have to say grab it by
the balls what are you gonna do what I'd
have to say and twist and twist but you
know it's funny because it was like my
dad was just he was such a great dad he
was a really engaged guy but you know I
mean he was he was a single father and
relatively young so maybe there were a
few boundaries of propriety that he
danced along but but he just encouraged
me you know um it just encouraged me to
be aggressive you know he was one of
those I think it's very hard for for
single parents period and I think it's
very hard for fathers and daughters
because you know just think if you're a
dad the world just looks like you know a
field of broken glass and potholes and
molten lava and then you've got this
little kitten and you just like so
terrified
put the kitten down so either they grip
very tightly or in my father's case they
throw you up in the air and you know and
expect that they've given you the skills
to land and that was definitely his
strategy you know you mentioned the the
the divorce which I have read was
amicable
and ended up resulting in you going with
your father and you have one sibling my
younger sister just able to stay with
your mom what was that hard or did it
not even occur to you to be hard because
it just is what it it was or was it was
that difficult being and did you have
constant contact or what was the dynamic
like you know it's interesting because I
think it was more the second for me like
it just was what was happening and and I
don't ever remember I don't ever
remember struggling in any grand way
with the way that things were going I
you know it's and look maybe that's my
nature I do my I know my parents worked
very hard to be loving and available to
both of us and I had like lots of access
to my mother and I talked to her all the
time and I called her for advice and
when she got to kind of be the fun mom
or the advice mom you know she didn't
have to discipline me and she could just
be the person who was there when I
needed like emotional support I I do
know that like one of the things that
resulted in at least when we were
younger was my sister and I but we
weren't super close but but I you know
lots of siblings aren't super close and
their kids whether they're living in the
same house or not they're fighting and
they're competitive but I but as we got
older I became like wildly protective of
my sister and and like my relationship
with her is so intensely loving and
affectionate now and I don't know maybe
if we lived in the same house driving
each other you know nuts all the time we
wouldn't be as close as we are now I
mean we spent the formative years of our
lives living in different houses what we
like the same stuff and and we care
about the same things and our
connections really deep so I can't I
don't ever remember kind of sitting up
at night feeling any kind of agony about
the fact that my parents were divorcing
I did watch them try very hard to stay
together like I do remember that when
got a divorce I was like they really
gave it a shot I could see that they
really like you I just they would break
up but they'd get back together and they
break up and they get back together and
I ride I'd like walking on them they'd
be making out on the couch I was like
they are really giving us a go so I was
like okay yeah I don't I don't ever I
don't ever remember it being like a
point of agony just things changed you
know and and maybe as a result I
tolerate change better than I would
otherwise or maybe I even crave change I
don't know has it been your demeanor to
generally look at things through a
positive lens like that where you would
frame what other people might try to
frame as a very difficult agonizing
experience into something that was or at
least is framed is something positive
that you benefited from or have you had
more of the time a tendency to frame
things negatively that's a really good
question and I think about that a lot
because I think that my my attitude or
my point of view about things is half
biochemistry and half like child rearing
my father is just like a like a
preternaturally optimistic person like
it's extraordinary I always make this
joke that if my father's house was on
fire he would like get a stick at
marshmallows like he just cannot be just
never down and I and so I think that I
inherited that and I maybe it's
attitudinal I think I just probably make
up the chemicals in my brain that kind
of keep me typically upbeat you know
what I mean and and I think it's
important because I think a lot of times
with people when people are or if they
have a hard time seeing the world
positively or struggling with depression
people like we need to see to look at it
a different way but I think that I
probably just make more of the chemicals
that enable me to be optimistic I just
you know I've never I've never really
been depressed but my father also was
just a walk it off dad he just did not
feel sorry for me and you know and and I
was not allowed of his sorry for myself
and so when things went wrong and this
is definitely sustained until I was an
adult I just I just get up and I keep
going and and that was because of you
know my father was raised he lost his
father what
it was very very young he's raised by
single mother and you know like
tumbledown Pittsburgh with the very few
opportunities for a black man at that
time and he just never felt sorry for
himself he was just like look I can
complain about the situation or I could
just keep moving and and I and I so I
think I've been nurtured in that way as
well which is the world is unfair there
you know it's shot through with [ __ ]
I still have to get up in the morning
and make a life for myself and so it's
probably a combination of those two
things where you would you say good at
following his advice of not only
grabbing life by the balls but twisting
which is a whole new level those are two
really like you could yeah like you can
gently grab balls you can't really
gently grab and twist balls yeah I mean
I don't know like it's hard to say like
I'm an it but I do think that like that
attitude of like you know just kind of
go and I wrote about a lot about it in
my book like the idea that like my
parents raised me to be brave and in
some ways maybe too brave but the result
has been like a relentlessness and in
the pursuit of the things that are
important to me and that's not the same
as like I don't really think about
things that way but it's just if I want
to do something that I do it and I don't
really worry too much about whether it's
gonna go my way not because I expect it
to go my way but because it doesn't
matter if it goes my way because it's
the engagement that's most meaningful to
me it's the effort I got it so the
engagement you mean sort of the dogged
persistence that you're developing the
engagement in your in your personal
goals like if I want to do something
whatever I don't know it has to pick
something really innocuous like if I
want to like hike every day for a month
or if I want to start meditating if I
don't dial it it's not as important to
me as is not looking back and saying to
myself I should have done it like it's
it's it's the doing for me that is the
reward and then sometimes things go away
and sometimes they don't but the thing I
find most upsetting is regret yeah
because that's that's something I have
control over in the sense of like if you
didn't do it you have nobody to blame
but yourself you know right you can
always attempt thank you you can't
predetermine yes yeah you can't
predetermine the outcome but you can
predetermine
the effort because the effort is is the
only thing that you own you can't own
results you can only own you can only
own initiative do you recall any you
mentioned your dad being a walk it off
dad I want to explore that a little bit
do you remember any while you were still
under his watch or not
early disappointments or self-inflicted
wounds and and how your dad responded or
mistakes yeah well this isn't this is
this isn't exactly a good example of a
disappointment but it's it's a perfect
example of his attitude I am I was going
to camp I was I was going to camp I must
have been about eight or nine no I'll
say nine and I was going to like you
know jujitsu camp and this was still
this was still during the free range
parenting era where you just got up in
the morning and you left at home and you
came back later and that stuff was your
responsibility because did you say eight
or nine and then jujitsu camp it's
making me think of the movie Hanauer
this bandit strains his daughter to be a
super killer as I pointed out it wasn't
the result that was important it was
just the effort so right I would ride my
bike to camp every day
and right at home and it was a good you
know it was a good rides like a
five-mile ride camp and I fell one day
coming down like a pill you know kind of
I don't know you know free this is like
this was like no helmets this was a long
time ago I'm very old look you know no
helmets just like willy-nilly your
backpack on and you know you're not
signalling and I fell and I hurt my arm
very badly and okay what I can't
remember but I contacted my dad and he's
like I'm not gonna come get you I can't
leave work you have to get home on your
own
and and I so I rode my bike back from
camp you know like another three four
miles and my arm was broken it was
definitely broken I'd broken my arm and
I got home and my dad was like your arms
not broken I'm you see this new stop
complaining oh it's a sore and the next
day I woke up it was like black and
swollen and he I had like you know like
lifted off the pillow and he finally
took me to the doctor and it was
absolutely like how come compound
fracture the bone hadn't come through
the skin but it was a multiple fracture
but my my I think at the time it felt
cruel but I think my dad's a larger
attitude was like no one is coming to
save you you have to save yourself you
have to find a way every single day to
save yourself
and and as a result I think that you
know as an adult I just don't spend a
lot of time like anguishing over what
other what's been done to me you know
and I was fine I did ride my bike home
and my arm was broken but I still got
home on my bike and you know then the
next day I got a super dope cast I just
raised like these I'm you know I know I
sound like everybody's mom but I just
feel like we're just we're curating
young people's experiences so
aggressively nowadays that they just
don't have any way to discover things
about themselves they don't develop not
just self-sufficiency but like a
curiosity about themselves and their
abilities and what they can tolerate and
what they can do if left alone because
they're just never left alone right and
I was just I had a lot of time alone
when I was a kid and and I still really
like being alone as an adult right and
also it strikes me that if you're so
protective of your child and your
child's ego that you effectively
disallow them to fail or engage with
risk that the the Delta the difference
between their actual competencies and
abilities for self-preservation and
their overinflated sense of their
capabilities is actually a huge
disservice oh absolutely and and their
sense of like you need to know what it
feels like to fail and
what what what comes next cuz what comes
next is what did I learn how can I
adjust how do i pivot how do I move
forward and just most people don't
develop those mental skills they just
they're crushed by failure and it's it's
just an unavoidable element of life and
and Minoso many people that I know who's
out of real I mean you know genuine love
parents like I just don't want to see my
kid in pain but like how are you gonna
how do people move through the the
planet how do they move through life
without pain that's that's it that's a
that's a false theory it can't be done
it just cannot be done and so people
just become incapacitated the first
minute they hit any kind of a speed bump
in in their lives and they just don't
know how they don't how to navigate
disappointment whereas I was just deeply
disappointed throughout my childhood so
I know exactly what it feels like that
didn't go my way moving on you know
well yeah it's it's it's it makes me
conjure my mind the image of this this
increasing sort of amplitude of pain
consequence over your life from like
childhood to adulthood where the
consequences grow potentially greater
and greater where in the beginning like
when you're a child
you're basically engaging with with pain
and I shouldn't say pain but failure in
many cases not all cases but many cases
where you're effectively in one of those
like birthday party blow-up sumo suits
do you know I'm talking about and it's
like alright you can so you can you can
sort of engage with failure that way and
if you get knocked on your ass it
doesn't there aren't really real
consequences right then we get you get
to high school college and it's like
okay you're out of the sumo suit but
you've got big kind of blow-up boxing
gloves on and huge head piece of
headgear and then you then when you get
out into some aspects of the real world
it's just a bare-knuckle brawl and so if
you haven't had a chance permanent
consequence yeah exactly so if you
haven't had the chance to get welled in
the face with the sumo suit you're not
going to be ready for the blow up boxing
gloves and the headgear and if you
certainly if you don't get whacked in
the face a few times doing that you're
just going to be crippled when you get
out into
real world and get you know drop kicked
in the face by someone who doesn't
follow the same rules and and and and
crippled in that way that you know and I
know you've interacted with people like
this in that way where you know when
something bad happens there their whole
monologue is like why me like why did
this happen to me you don't understand
what I'm going through it's like you're
not you're not special everybody is
experiencing the same thing everybody
everybody's heart is being broken
everybody isn't getting the job they
want everybody isn't gonna sleep with it
but the hot person they want everybody
is experiencing this same failure these
same injuries but you just don't know
how to tolerate them you are not special
and that's not the same as saying your
potential for being special
you know you dude there's nothing
anybody's doing now that hasn't already
been done it that won't be done in the
future that I those those kinds of
personalities drive me crazy because
they just there's they're so stuck and
boring what did what did you think you
were going to be when you grew up when
you were in high school or college
oh god in high school I it's so
interesting cuz I was like super
academic and I think I would thought I'd
be an attorney I was really I was like
you know I was a kid big activist and I
organized and Marge turned it all that
stuff and I was I was if I can't really
look into you know the Outing Club and I
rock climbed and all that stuff so I
thought I was gonna be like an
environmental lawyer um either an
environmental lawyer an environmental
engineer and then I got to and I wanted
I really wanted to go to a school that
was like like really grounded and like a
relationship to nature so I was applying
to like you know Marlborough College and
read and and bard and these schools that
were like out in the woods and I ended
up going to Dartmouth which is you know
in New Hampshire and has this big land
grant around it and and I thought I
would be an environment engineer and I
think I just took like the first
prerequisite math course for engineering
I was like yeah okay so that just not
gonna be there's nothing I always loved
I always loved science but I'm just a
person of letters I guess and I I didn't
have the appetite for it it wasn't as
glamorous as I thought I think when I
took my first engineering I did I think
I've got through the mouth
like did fine like I've applied myself
and I got a good grade and then I went
to my like you know an introduction to
engineering and three and it was about
like building like a fecal matter
treatment plant and I was like this
isn't feeling like hugging trees at all
man we're just talking about poop all
day so then what did you just have this
great access existential angst or did
you sort of shift to something else
immediately following that I was always
doing kind of like performing things on
the side like I I went to a high school
that had a performing arts kind of like
magnet or like a pocket school within
the the the regular school called the Ju
D McAteer School of the Arts so I was
kind of doing my regular classwork and
then doing like improv and stuff and
sketch on the side and then I went to
Dartmouth and I was doing some of the
same stuff like you know isn't one of
those infernal you know Ivy League a
cappella groups that have been
popularized since then by shows like
Glee and so is always kind of doing that
as a hobby because it just never felt
like a real job and I graduated and I
was I was living in San Francisco and I
was working for a conservation
organization it was like a killer it was
like I got like my dream job it was a
group that purchased like blighted urban
land it turned in at the parks and
underserved neighborhoods that didn't
have any outdoor space for kids to play
and you know I was like the mission was
great because it was it wasn't just sign
of conservation of conservation sake it
was like conservation focused on
engaging underserved communities and it
was the grooviest and I was just
miserable and I just were you miserable
because I just I didn't know it was a
really good question you know it was
like why why if I have my dream job in
the city of my birth why am I so unhappy
and I just a lost soul searching and I
realized it was because I for the first
time in my life I wasn't doing anything
created I wasn't performing and so I I'm
a problem I'm a problem solver
I'm a matrix builder I was like well how
can I solve this problem right now
and I looked at all the ways that I
could get on stage and sano comedy was
the only thing I didn't need to know
anyone for have an agent or a band or
connections I could just do stand-up
right away and so I started studying and
watching the precursor to Comedy Central
which was this network called ha a very
short-lived network and make taking
notes and then you know after a while
just kind of screwed up the courage to
go and do an open mic and then that was
it was just transformational I was like
oh this is what I want to do with my
life was the thinking immediately on how
to turn performance into a career or did
you did you expect that you would
continue doing your job and doing
stand-up on the side like was it a
career move from when you first built
the matrix and decided on stand-up or
was it you know what this is going to be
great I'll continue doing this job and
I'll scratch my creative performance
itch on the weekends with open mikes
yeah it's so funny because like I don't
think I even realized that stand-up
comedy was a job you know I know it's
like a really bookish kid that you know
a lot of guys will have these stories
about how they grew up you know with
like red fox you know on vinyl that they
listen to hundreds of times or you know
following you know Letty Bruce or you
know these idols or Bill Hicks I just I
didn't like I remember seeing live on
the Sunset Strip when I was a kid but
like I just thought Richard Pryor was an
alien like I magically came down to do
this thing it just the idea that that
was like a vocation was just not in my
head so I remember seeing stand-up at
Dartmouth when I was like a sophomore
and coming out of a show and being like
like do you got like do people know that
this like you can go and have this
feeling for an hour like this is
insanity
like I just remember like everything
hurt from laughing my face and my
stomach and I just never experienced
live comedy before so it it it they
didn't dovetail into like a job at first
it was just I something I was gonna do
for fun I kept my day job 100% and I
kept her a long time I I also didn't
want to be like one of these kind of
like miserable you know sweating
stand-ups were like gripping there you
know kind of inky notebook and sleeping
on their buddy's couch you know like I
was in a relationship and and I had a
job that paid great and I could make
flyers for my shows at work I was
embezzling you know a copy paper and
then I'd push pins as well as
aggressively as I could so I I was I was
and I still am of the opinion that like
you should absolutely keep your day job
which I know is not the most popular I'm
impressive I'm of the same opinion
absolutely yeah yeah I think it I think
it gives you a freedom people think it
traps them but I think it gives you this
incredible freedom to just pursue art
for art's sake yeah and let a job pay
for it and do it for so long that
everything you do is just for joy and
and it changes the way that you it
changes the way that you approach your
art you know I would like get up and I'd
go to work like 7:00 and I 6 or 7 the
morning am i working till 4:00 and then
I jump in the car die drive two hours to
Sacramento do you know said I come back
at midnight I do it all over again and
but I could do that and then it was just
purely about the experience of
performing and not about whether I was
getting paid or not so I did that for a
long time before I finally quit my job
now for those people who don't know the
geography of of Northern California
where I lived for 17 years and
coincidentally this the high school that
you went to is that now the Ruth asawa
school on O'Shaughnessy it so you have
it up there at the court well it kind of
like the access of Twin Peaks / Glen
Canyon exactly so I literally lived for
five or six years about a quarter mile
from that school right there a big city
even though I think you feel it when you
live there it feels like it but it's
like it's an intimate place me a place
and and given the density of San
Francisco and the fact that it I'm not
going to go so I don't know if people
would consider it a comedy town but
there's certainly clubs and so why would
you go all the way to Sacramento
Sacramento is not for those people who
don't know the area it's not like a ten
minute drive away from services are
it's far it's always had sisters always
had a reputation for being a comedy town
like the big comedy towns in the United
States from comedians perspectives our
San Francisco Chicago Boston and New
York LA is not I mean LA is a company
town but it's not a comedy town and San
Francisco was always one of those places
that people saw as like a real crucible
for kind of original comedy you know it
was like where the alts comedy movement
happened and you know Marc Maron and
Janeane Garofalo and and these kind of
alternative comics Brian Posehn came out
of and it was a comedy town but when I
started doing comedy it was like the
beginning of the contraction of the
comedy economy so there was a period of
time when there were just hundreds of
comedy clubs everywhere and you could
make a living doing stand-up he could
kind of go from place to place and you
could get a gig and you could get paid
and I started doing stand-up at the
beginning of the end of the comedy
bubble so when I started doing stand-up
the club community was contracting and
and some of the big clubs in San
Francisco were closing I think at one
point they were maybe like five or six
active clubs and then by the time I was
working consistently there were only two
and there was just a lot of competition
for stage time and to get good at comedy
you can't just do it like once a weekend
you know you need to be on stage like
every night it's it's it's like being a
high diver like you know what it's it's
literally like Malcolm Gladwell's 10,000
hours and you're not going to get 10,000
hours of stand-up hanging out in San
Francisco like you have to go everywhere
and and take every single opportunity to
be onstage that you can get so I would
drive to Sacramento I would drive to
Fresno I would do these terrible you
know like bar shows and in Menlo Park
and oh god I don't even remember some of
the places Cooper Cupertino and Martinez
I mean you would just go anywhere that
you could get six minutes on stage and
other people trying to get those same
six minutes so it was really competitive
I mean the court the culture room I
think was pretty supportive like
comedians were supportive of each other
but it just there just wasn't enough
stage time so you just do anything and
go anywhere to get it I want to ask
about this comedy contraction
we won't spend too much time on this
because I don't want to take us
completely off the reservation but what
happened I mean it was like beanie
babies like people right get really the
beanie babies that's like nope
comedy isn't cool anymore and then like
all the clubs closed what was it just a
macro economic downturn I mean what
happened I think I think it was there
were three factors one factor was just
there was just a glut there just you
know it be it for a live comedy in in
some ways in the 70s and 80s was kind of
a new thing and it's not like people had
been doing stand-up prior to that but
the proliferation of santim comedians in
in in the culture really started
happening at that time and what that was
fueled by I honestly don't know like why
were there so many more comics doing
stand-up in the 70s and 80s maybe
because that was the period where there
were these superstar comics that were
kinda you know I'm trying to think of
who would have been really popular
besides like Bill Hicks and I could say
that though maybe it's a just like
celebrity celebrity chefs in the last 15
years yeah exactly and and you know
partly reason why there are so many more
celebrity chefs is because they started
to be celebrity chefs on television
right and so if you think about that in
terms of comedy what you what you see is
oh that's a job I can make money at that
whereas people weren't really
encountering live comedy if they didn't
go to a live comedy show and so you
start to see these guys on TV and you
think and honestly when when ha the
precursor to Comedy Central started they
needed like they needed comics and they
needed opportunities they needed clubs
they needed needed content it was a 24
hour network so there were there were
some good comedians on that station and
there was some really really shitty
really and so a lot of people watching
probably thought well I can do that you
know I also think about guys like you
know Sam Kinison and angeas clay there
was kind of like a golden era in that
time we were seeing all those people on
TV then we were seeing a lot of people
that were like really subpar and a lot
of people are thinking well if that guy
can write you know five crappy minutes
about an airplane
can good then you come out with this
explosion and comedy clubs which were a
relatively new phenomenon I mean when
Joan Rivers was doing a stand-up she was
doing stand-up in strip clubs there were
very few comedy clubs and and comedy was
kind of a part of a vaudeville approach
so you'd you'd hire a singer and then
you'd hire a comic but there wasn't a
there weren't places dedicated to comedy
so these comedy clubs opened it was a
really easy to way to make money because
comics comics weren't that expensive and
you know you had a two-drink minimum
people coming they would get wasted you
have huge margins on your booze so these
comedy clubs started proliferating and
then they just peak there was just peak
clubs that was a saturation yeah
unsustainable so they started to
contract because of market saturation
the economy started to contract in the
80s and people could watch comedy on TV
the proliferation of comedy on
television affected people going out to
see it in a club so they were like kind
of those three factors all all kind of
intersecting and when it happened it was
really aggressive like I said I think
there are maybe like five or six comedy
clubs in San Francisco when I was in
high school and by the time I was doing
stand-up in my 20s there were two Wow so
you you you would do and you know and
they were attracting like you know like
high-end like peak talent so for example
this club's still there it's called the
punchline punchline I've been there a
few times and there was the punchline
there was cobs and those are still the
daily two clubs and maybe there's some
minor clubs that have sprung up since
then but you know they would book these
big headliners so the only time you
could go up if you were an amateur like
a young comic was on a Sunday or
Wednesday and there'd be 20 other guys
trying to get on you know as well and it
would be wildly competitive and you
wouldn't be getting paid you know and
and then you'd be super anxious because
you'd be like hoping okay I need to go
open I need to destroy because I want
this club owner to hire me again so I
can't go up and I can't work out I can't
I can't fail in front of this guy
because he won't see this like you know
when you watch like an Olympic skater
during practice and they're falling I
mean that's
that's what practice is for you know
practice is for like finding your weak
spots and and reinforcing them but when
you're up in front of a comedy club
owner and you it's been six months
you've been trying to get out of this
club and you finally get five minutes
it's got to be a monster five minutes
and so there was just no way to improve
you can't improve can't I was gonna say
how do you how do you get in your rough
drafts and I mean how do you work on the
material tribe - marty is oh I see I see
see you'd write work out the case with
exactly the crew at the such-and-such
casino and God knows where Turlock and
there fou bars or rooster tee feathers
or you know one of these other yeah and
and there was this um you know it's
different than being an author or an
athlete or even a musician because
there's an autonomy to comedy absolutely
but you need other people you you can't
do it it can't just sit around your
place practicing you know what I mean
like with your music you know it's you
know you fit you're sharp or flat you
know if you hit all the notes you know
if the tempo is right but with comedy
the only way it works is in front of an
audience and so you're very dependent on
stage time and that's it's everything
when you're a young comic is stage time
well do you remember your early content
and what kind of what was your approach
early on do you remember the first and
maybe I mean a different way to approach
this you could take it answer it however
you like do you remember the first time
that you bombed or the what is your
first memory that comes to mind of
bombing oh god I bombed so many times
it's just it all seeps together into an
inky blackness um II comic any comic can
tells me that ever bombed is lying and
and and again the only way to get
funniest to bomb you know whenever no
one ever gets funnier after they kill
you know they just walk on that follow
that bridges or they drop the mic you
know maybe shots of their friends I mean
you really need to you really need to
bomb and bomb hard to get funny I
remember doing this one show Oh God so
there was there was an open mic in a
laundromat in like like South of Market
around the police station there so what
maybe like
you know 8 the mission or something like
that for people San Francisco I think
was called brainwash I think the the
place was called brainwash and they
would have this open mic in the back of
this laundromat and in comics no you
know with these open mics with these
local open mics typically there are no
actual audience members in the audience
it is just a room full of comedians
waiting for you to be done so that they
can try out their material well you know
look all of them looking at their
notebooks not listening not laughing and
you're just kind of trying to get it out
and pause where you think the laughter
might occur if you were in front of
actually human beings and I just did I
said where I just I did not get one
laughs and I remember that would not
even like it not even like a cursory
titter and I remember just sighs just
like really like just a wall of silence
and I got off I was even thinking about
right now it's so funny to me like I
called it's hard to a girlfriend
afterwards I was like oh my god like I
couldn't even call that that said I
don't know what that was but it was so
funny to me that I didn't get a laugh
like it was it there was this there was
this like bulletproof 'no set that just
made me impervious to anything ever
going wrong and my in my life or career
again and and every like even when I'm
talking about now it's Mother's Day he'd
smile at my face because it was so funny
how how little how little I was able to
elicit out of that audience but but it
made it it made me it just made me so
mentally strong was that the immediate
response that you had I mean or were you
in the middle of the set when you're
like in the back your mind thinking wow
no one is laughing was there did you go
from like a pan it was it like the
reverse of the five stages agree for
like what or did you just go straight to
like yeah [ __ ] this is great
this is gonna make a great story however
many years from now I'm Tim Ferriss
podcast
well what mediums love is is agony I
mean it's we dine out on it as
definitely like our stock and trade so a
comedian very quickly transitions from
oh my god this is the worst night of my
life - oh my god this is gonna make a
great story that happens almost
instantaneously
so so we have a little bit of a we have
some armor and we're in that regard cuz
you know you could just you we could
wake up like naked and shivering on the
side of the road with like no money and
no phone and you know and not speak the
local language and you'd be thinking
okay what if I live this is gonna make a
killer story so I think in the moment I
just thought I had watched a couple
other people go up and not do very well
either I was prepared for it not going
my way and I just thought I'm just and I
think also there's a discipline to
comedy that if you're not a community
you can't understand which is that you
got to get up and do your set there is
there is no you don't get to tap out
like tapping out is tapping out is true
failure you know if you if you went up
and you had a bad set well you just need
to write new jokes but if you go up and
you give up that's true failure for a
comedian and and there are some really
famous examples of this online I don't
know if you know the comedian Bill burr
but I so I interviewed Bill burr about a
year and a half ago and I played the
video which he had never seen or he
claimed he had never seen real he still
has some psychic here some he has some
trauma music so can you for people who
don't know the story can you please
describe it because it's just so he was
he was doing like one of those big like
radio you know those radio station
concerts like the Jingle Ball or
whatever and I don't remember it was
called the weenie roast I think it was
the weenie roast
that's what's one of the shows like some
locals do you know a rock you know like
one of those shows and it's like you
know I don't know Weezer's too cool of a
band it would be like Nickelback and you
know some other fan that sounds like a
Nickelback and then nobody man you never
heard of anyway and but they paid they
they I don't know why people still do
this but you know if your comic and
someone offers you money you take it so
they would hire a comic to kind of warm
up the crowd you know early in the day
and you know no one no one pays to see
Nickelback and then wants to sit through
15 minutes of stand-up you know
everyone's drunk and they're not even
facing forward you know I mean this is
like the work like there's nothing the
only thing worse than performing in
front of an outdoor audience is
performing in front of people who are
eating yeah yeah this is like this is
like a tailgate at like 11:00 a.m. or
1 p.m. or something yeah everybody's
been you know everybody like busted out
there like you know their marijuana
brownie recipe for the year they're all
they completely looped you know like one
of their eyes is completely dilated and
the other one is like falling out of
their head nobody cares about your jokes
about your mom and your family so he
starts doing stand-up and it just
immediately starts getting booed and
it's just this dislike this tidal wave
of disdain and he knows if he doesn't
finish he will not get paid but it's not
like it's not like snot like silence you
could tolerate right but like people are
screaming at him to get offstage and he
he makes it very clear to the audience
II have to watch it because I'll never
be able to do it justice but he makes it
very clear to the audience that he is
not leaving this stage until he does his
10 minutes that he does not care how
they feel about him and he's any
counting down every minute he's like
nine minute you [ __ ] [ __ ] I hope
your mother gets cancer in the center of
her [ __ ] so it's a it's just a
demonstration of tenacity you know he
later you know he was embarrassed by it
but every comedian understands you know
this kind of this kind of blood battle
that you sometimes have with an audience
where you know you're not they're not
gonna scare you and they're not gonna
drive you away you're going to deliver
the the material that you were hired to
deliver you're going to make your money
and then you're gonna go off and spend
it on Light beer and chicken wings but
but no one is you will not be deterred
and so so I think because you understand
that as a community very early on in
your career no matter what happens on
stage you know III will not be moved so
I just I had material to do and I did it
and I think I remember right thinking
almost immediately well kay I'm not
gonna get any laughs I'm just gonna kind
of like listen to this set and see what
it feels like see what the words feel
like see what might play in front of
actual people but but it started to get
really delicious and I think if you
watched the Bill burr video you'll also
see that he starts to really enjoy it it
starts to be like the
kind of like savory masochism towards
the end where he just he's so powerful
in his in his in his lack of caring you
know what I mean like and and and I I
you you watch it and it's masti studied
because he goes from kind of anguish to
rage this kind of delightful detachment
by the end of the set and I've seen I've
seen some other guys do similar stuff
and it's always really fun to watch so a
couple of a couple of things that I want
to use his teasers for people who should
watch this video I think I think it
wasn't Phil I'm almost 100 positive in
Philadelphia I know but yeah I think it
was Philadelphia because he started
ridiculing rocky and he said your hero
is a fictional person and just tearing
into them and he basically for the for
half of his set just decided to abandon
his material and just attack these
people in the town and ways no no
generally which is a no-no generally
like like if people hate you like you
know there's they're like these
unwritten rules of comedy and one of
them is like you don't if some of the
people in the audience hate you like
don't turn all of them against you yeah
and this is a sidebar but don't forget
what you were gonna say there's another
very famous video very famous and it
happened at the punchline in San
Francisco where there's a high plane
he's a good guitar comic and a guy's
heckling him and it's kind of just
combative back and forth but nothing too
extreme but then the guy gets up and he
comes towards the the stage you know
whatever to defend himself or the girl
he's with something like that and the
guy just hauls off and hits him in the
head with a guitar not funny it's tragic
but Jesus Christ but what happens is up
until that beat the whole audience has
been on the comedian's side against this
guy and it is a it is a hairpin turn
from them being like yeah shut up
cuz guy cuz you know the comics like hey
you know people can't enjoy the show
because you're talking keep you know
keep it down and then he hits this guy
in the heart he's just turns on him just
like instantaneous like you know
Frankenstein's monster mob just a
pitchforks come flying out and
one of the unwritten rules of comedy is
that you know you just don't you want to
try to at all cause avoid turning
everybody against you which so so bill
broke a bunch of rules but but he just
he never gave up you know which I think
it becomes this you know it's like the
Rudy mo and at the end of the movie like
man that sucked but you stuck in there
and he got a standing over I mean every
was every standing but he got massive
applause from the audience at the end
which is just like what the [ __ ] like it
didn't even fit into like any mental
heuristic of comedy that it could expect
it was it was great prison that was
straight prison yard dynamics right
nobody backing down nobody's backing
down and he just you know I think there
was like a thousand of them to whatever
probably like ten thousand of them to
one of him and he just did not back down
clap at the end oh my god so I wasn't
gonna go to heckling but why not since
we're already here do you have any
memorable heckling stories did you
recall the first time you got heckled
god yeah I mean again there's I mean I
mean I started doing stand-up like 25
years ago so I at this point like all
the sets of just kind of blended but an
heckling can be lots of different things
it doesn't always have to be like the
conventional kind of you suck heckle one
I had one time where this woman and this
kind of dovetails perfectly with the old
like don't turn the audience against you
where this woman was talking to me she
was sitting the front row and she was
talking to me the entire show just loud
enough that I could hear her but not
really loud enough so the audience could
hear her except for the people right
around her and it was driving me crazy
that's awful it was like a bee in my ear
and as a result I just seemed insane
stopping to yell at this person that no
one could hear you know it was a very
effective because she just completely
derailed my show and I just seemed like
a dick because I was gay like shut up
lady and but no one could hear what she
was saying
and really that was I remember they
really went off the rails last night and
I generally have a rule of hecklers that
unless they're really disruptive to the
entire room I just never addressed them
because what you do is again you derail
a show for 500 or a thousand people to
deal with one person and and and
everyone's never gonna really understand
what's going on unless that person is so
loud that they're that they're affected
everybody else's enjoyment of the night
but but sometimes the affectionate
hecklers are the worst because because
they don't like you know typically
hecklers just want to be a part of the
show and so you know they say something
is slam them a little bit they shut up
because they think they're helping you
out it was the famous line is they'll
come up and be like hey like I helped
you out I'm like buddy I came with jokes
I don't I don't I don't have a box
Jumper in my action right I showed up
ready to go when people are affectionate
you can't insult them and they're
they're the most unmanageable kind of
Hell by affectionate me so I was like I
love you this one girl at one show in
San Francisco just so drunk I'm just
cross-eyed and for that 90 minutes I was
on stage I and I was just like lady like
you're what like what all you are doing
is making me want to hit you in the head
with this microphone stand your
affection is is not welcome here and
everybody else is like staring at this
woman and but she this is a genuine
expression of emotion for this person
that is destroying a my joy completely
so you know I I really have a habit of
just not talking to hecklers what did
you do in that case did you ignore her I
think that I kept saying like thank you
that's super sweet shut the [ __ ] up that
was like like you know clearly you
weren't hugged it up as a child I mean I
just imagine he got mean because it was
just like I couldn't get this woman to
stop talking and and I think the people
around her got embarrassed and they
eventually kind of shut her up which was
nice and I don't think they're any other
really good actors that oh I had one guy
and it's a mental discipline too because
you know like again like it's your show
you have the microphone you're in
control you know I think the audience
thinks they're in control but they're
not I mean that the Bill burr scenario
is a perfect example
the person with the microphone has all
the power and as long as they as long as
it cannot be moved they will they will
eventually win but I had him this one
guy it was sitting like really close to
the stage was like a group of 12 people
and they were all like laughing their
asses off and then he was just arms
crossed just look like he just had just
eaten a big scoop of fecal matter and I
just I was all he was all I could see
like you don't even make the whole
audience it disappeared and it was just
like straight vignette on this guy's
like sourpuss face it was just wrecking
my whole night and I finally said if you
don't want to be here just [ __ ] go
man I'll give you your money back I
cannot look at your face for one more
minute and you are harshing my mellow so
hard and his and and any left and I I
didn't feel bad about it and then I went
on with the show and his girls he had a
bad day nobody else at the table wanted
to leave they were like you know good
riddance to bad rubbish
you know he went on and that's the
people enjoy their night so but I get
that was me that was my you know I
should have been disciplined enough not
to be distracted by you know old
sourpuss but I just thought I'm only
human you know at the Grinch is if the
Grinch is sitting in the front row you
know something must be done when you
were just getting started how did you
get better at comedy and what I mean by
that is you're very smart you like you
mentioned matrix capable did you do any
type of post game analysis
did you watch video of yourself did you
watch video of other comics well how did
you hone your craft or or or maybe a
better question is what helped the most
in honing your craft right that's a good
question
you know it's interesting like I think
that there's a definite math to comedy
and then there's also a secondary kind
of like ineffability you know what I
mean and and I guess what I mean is like
you can learn how to be a better comic
but you can't learn how to be a comic or
even had a different way I really wanted
to be an engineer and I could have
really suffered and struggled through
like that high like the L of
that would I would need to become an
engineer but it would never be
effortless for me and I think with
comedy there are people who very workman
like can learn how to do comedy and then
there's some people were just naturally
comedic and they still have to work to
be better at it you know like you say
both still has to train even though he
was born with you know more fast-twitch
muscles than everybody else he still has
to train to become a champion so I feel
like with comedy there you know you know
people can be the class clown or they
can be that guy's a naturally funny
there's still a methodology and there's
still a mathematics to becoming a comic
and then at the same time if they have
this this ephemeral ineffable kind of
understanding of the math of comedy
they're gonna be able to do something
magical with those skills so for me I
don't know that I thought I was a funny
kid but I was an observer and I was
really nerdy and a little bit of a
social pariah so storytelling became a
way to make friends you know what I mean
like - like a grey sheet myself I would
I you know I would kind of like try to
talk my way into situations or if I was
in a social situation talk really fast
try to keep myself engaging not be
rejected so like that was what I brought
to it was like that combination of being
an outsider and an observer and then and
then using those skills to try to kind
of connect with people but with comedy
like I never took any classes I never
read any books you know they're they're
definitely people who can say oh you
know there's a total methodology to
comedy it's you know the rule of threes
and you know stretching the stretching
reality to the point of breaking but not
past it I mean there you know some
specific what's the rule of threes the
rule of threes is that I mean definitely
maintain your train of thought but right
I probably won't even be able articulate
it properly it's it's just that like if
you're going to do a series of jokes or
a series of builds to a punchline it
needs to be three and also if you're
going to do any kind of a diversion if
you're going to lead people in one
direction then snap around to a
different kind of absurdist result you
can't do that in you can't do that in
two it has to that has to be there has
to be that the pace of it has to be
three I say and then past three you're
starting to you know
draw things out too long but two doesn't
give people enough of a Auld into a
false sense of security before you kind
of pull the rug out from under them as
soon as you start explaining that the
math of comedy like that if it makes any
sense you know I mean like it's this
it's those two things you know someone
who's really gifted at physics they're
they know that there are rules but still
they see things that other people can't
see you know what I mean they they see
the world as numbers and data and the
rest of us are just like table chair
water sex so I I guess the way that I
did it was that I uh I'm also really an
undisciplined comedian and what I mean
is like like there's a there's a
documentary about Garry Shandling out
right now which I haven't watched but
but I'm sure that this is in there
because he was very famous for being a
really disciplined writer like he would
get up and he would write every single
day and sometimes it would be pages and
pages of material without fail other
comics quake hey let's get a beer
they're like no I have to write and
every day he would write like you know
on this like legal this is this is
probably true and apocrypha at the same
time on this like legal I knew about
this tiny handwriting he was just write
and write and write and write I do not
do that I've never worked that way I
just get on stage I try a bunch of stuff
I keep what works I know what works I
already know right away what works I'll
run off stage I'll write down the things
that I new hit I'll write down the
things I know didn't hit and then I'll
go back and try it again dropping the
stuff that wasn't good and putting new
stuff in I record my sets but I never I
I cannot listen to my own voice so I
have hours and hours of material on tape
that I just have never listened to so I
don't know why I still engage in that
behavior when it's clearly not useful to
me but but I I think the more you do it
the more you intuitively understand oh
this is a rich area people are
connecting with this this other stuff
there's also something you learn as you
move through comedy which is it's not
just important to get a laugh like does
this material say something specific and
personal about me because when your baby
comic every joke is meaningful to you
because you only have like eight jokes
right and so even if they're stupid or
juvenile or unsophisticated or
valueless or Corliss you'll still do
that because that's all you have and
then as you get older you start anything
okay like I want to have a body of work
here does this hang together does it
have a strong point of view does it have
an identity and then those other jokes
start to fall away and then the material
really becomes about trying to tell some
kind of a story about yourself the way
you perceive the world and then that's
how you shape it and so sometimes things
that are really funny go away things
that are less funny stay because they
they're more impactful does that make
sense yeah does it make sense
absolutely I think that's true for
musicians I think it's true for many
different artists writers too probably
for writers it's like I'm gonna find a
space that's that it really says
something about like my accumulated
understanding and knowledge of the world
and it's not just enough to say
something like I need to say something
that's uniquely mine you know and as
something you can only do with by being
prolific because you need to be able to
let things go in order to figure out
what should stay definitely
yeah there's I mean there's a certain
volume to it or thinking of it almost as
a funnel and you know I think and I
certainly hope for the sake of art not
to sound like an old man but I guess
that's what I'm turning into for the
sake of our society in general I would
hope just seeing the number of hatchet
jobs and the amount of yellow journalism
and click baiting with pieces that have
not been fact-checked and so on and take
down pieces of folks who are otherwise
doing actually a lot of good in the
world but people feel like no
compunction about running pieces that
get a lot of clicks because that's the
only metric they're focused on at some
point go from you know what what can I
write that will get the most clicks -
what can I write that I will be proud of
that may or may not and and yeah I think
you can figure out a way to make it a
non binary decision in other words you
could figure out something you can be
proud of that is simultaneously likely
to have fought to find some type of
sizable audience right and I think in
the beginning
there's a temptation particularly if you
have quit your job and you're like
where's my next rent check coming from
how can I appeal to the widest number of
people possible and that's a very
precarious position or mindset to put
yourself into if you're hoping to do
anything creatively evergreen hay right
and I also like it's interesting like
you know like when I went to school you
know we had we had the you know the
honor system and and and you were just
expected to hold yourself to a high
standard because that was what was right
that's what you did you know what I mean
you just you were gonna be you were
gonna be called upon to stand behind
your work and and so you tried to work
very hard to make sure that you can
defend it I think that I don't think
that it's like we're any less ethical
than we have ever been it's just like
you said our metrics have changed like
and I think that people value Fame for
fames sake rather than for the like the
foundational reasons that people become
famous and and I think that's the
problem and I don't think it just exists
in journalism I think I think the people
value infamy or they can't distinguish
between Fame and infamy and you know
with the 24-hour news cycle like you
know a the bright bursts is as
meaningful as a slow burn and I don't
really know I don't I actually don't
really know what we do or what should be
done or what should happen to counteract
that other than people start to maybe
get hip to it and start rejecting you
know baseless journalism and and you
know it's just it's just so hard to
decide oh no I find it I let me take the
back I find it very easy to distinguish
between things that seem like they've
been thoroughly vetted and things that
are [ __ ] but I think that people are
working very hard to make it harder for
the rest of us to distinguish between
the two so there are you know without me
sounded like a crazy person there are
nefarious you know forces at work trying
to make it very hard for us to figure
out what's real and what's not real and
I think we have to start to raise people
who are just more critical thinkers but
it's hard to be a critical thinker when
you're just scrolling through your
Instagram feed looking at like butts and
cupcakes all day long
have you been have you been watching my
my feet are you looking over my shoulder
are you one of the nefarious forces I'm
following you and I know I know what
you're into Isis you know I have to I'll
admit there was a day and you would
think supposedly being a tech investor
and all this stuff for ten years then I
would figure this out there was a day
when I was scrolling through cupcakes
and thongs and I looked up at my my
profile and I was like wait a minute
people can see what I follow you know
fortunately I've systematically
dismantled and deliberately tarnished
any semblance of any reputation I might
have very deliberately so that I don't
feel I have any Stepford Wives polished
to preserve so good and that's so
interesting to me and it's different
than just being a slob what you're
seeing is I refuse to create a box
within which I will be kept by others
and I think like that comes also from a
curiosity about the world I actually
think that like people are trying to
remain perfect all the time
are fear-driven like that's not that's
not that's not a that's not a position
of strength you're not me people think
they're maintaining position of strength
when they're trying to maintain an
appearance of perfection but that is by
its very nature a posture of fear which
is I cannot be seen to have
imperfections that cannot be seen to
have flaws that there can be no chinks
in my armor and that's I am I'm
terrified of being judged but there is
something very liberating and I think it
comes from age as well and from
experience I don't mean experience like
resume but just having experiences to
realize how little you know and how the
only way to learn is to constantly be
like skinning your knees and that that
doesn't go away like you're the older
you get the more you know that you know
very little and that you cannot learn
if you are constantly trying to maintain
a posture of perfection absolutely and
that's why I'm a total mess well if you
know if you don't practice skinning your
knees just to like really bleed the
metaphor for all it's worth if you don't
practice skinning your knees you're not
going to develop the callus for ink sort
of increasingly painful grades of
sandpaper this is really awkwardly
overextended now but the the point being
if you operate from a place of fear and
want to please this this nebulous
majority more than you want to please
yourself and that's not to say that I'm
always I've always view my entire life
and all my decisions as a singular locus
of control and the palm of my hand and I
care what no one thinks that's not true
because that's not how humans have
evolved but if you are if you are
deferring to others your perception of
what others want on the small things
then it's going to become harder on the
medium things and then impossible and
then it's going to become harder and
impossible on the big things and for
that reason I I find it very valuable to
deliberately expose yourself to
different types and levels of discomfort
so that you can actually stand up for
the important stuff when it matters
because if you don't practice on the
smaller stuff for instance I give if I'm
so humiliated by the fact that I like
gorgeous female asses oh my go my god
and I put something up about I put up
this picture so this is what I do
occasionally when I'm like you know what
I think I'm getting a little a little
fat and happy and complacent and maybe I
have too much FOMO or something like
that I will I remember at one point this
I put up this photo of this gorgeous
like Latin
ass and female and and it said like now
go philia and I had this in Spanish this
explanation of this fake condition which
was now gone algo philia anyway I think
there's now anyway last nalgas is like
ass in anyway so I put this up on
Instagram Spanish Spanish for ass man
that's right it's Spanish for like ass
man ass man syndrome right or ass man
disorder and I put it up and is to be
expected there is immediate outrage I
mean there are there are plenty of
people who think it's kind of funny
plenty of people are like high-five and
then there are plenty of other people
who are just completely outraged
disgusted with this fact that I find
attractive women attractive and yes
outrageous yeah it's so but I left it up
because I like to call my audience
number one you don't want to be here
please I invite you to unfollow me
exactly right looks like the sourpuss in
the front row it's like let me give you
a yeah you look you look like you're
unhappy but you're still here mm-hmm and
let me give you like let me give you
another reason to leave if I'm not your
thing because pinion is valuable to you
like I think there's a freedom and
saying I don't need everybody to like me
that's you know I mean i think i think
that like there is something very
meaningful in saying like this is who I
am I'll defend it but I'm not here to be
savaged by you and honestly we don't
know each other I don't care what you
think anyway you know or maybe that
person makes you think more bugs
critically about what you did and then
you take the big booty picture down I
don't know but but I think you put it up
purposefully to see what you were gonna
get back which I totally did
entertaining and there are another other
there are cases just so I don't sound
like a complete dick there aren't other
cases where I put something up without
really thinking about it
and I do get feedback and realize you
know what that's actually a really kind
of insensitive thing to put up and I
didn't think it through
take it down and there are cases when I
do that and people give me hopefully
constructive feedback that isn't just
spitting acid into my face and that's
and I take it down so I do pay attention
at the same time I try to keep in mind
advice that I was given years ago I
don't remember who gave me this advice
but they said the advice was it's not
about how many people don't get it it's
about how many people get it mm-hmm
as long as you have a certain critical
mass whatever that means to you and
there's an article called 1,000 true
fans my Kevin Kelly that everybody
should read to this effect if you're
creative but as long as you have a
critical mass and it could be a very
small number of people who love your
stuff mm-hmm hey that's all that matters
that's like a pass-fail right as long as
you have that pass like you're green and
instead of focusing on the vast majority
you hate your shits like look there are
millions of people who hate like
Christopher Nolan's stuff there are
millions of people who can't stand Wes
Anderson it's like look some people just
aren't going to [ __ ] like Wes
Anderson exactly exactly you see that so
it is really interesting also because I
think if you're an artist specifically
this is a really important conversation
to have with yourself which is like when
I first started out at stand-up you know
this is like kind of the period where
like def Comedy Jam was really popular
and you know and and for lack of a
better way of articulating like black
comedy had a very specific like looking
feeling style and tempo and I just
wasn't doing that kind of comedy and I
wasn't ever going to be able to do that
kind of comedy it wasn't who I was it
wasn't experientially what I was doing
and I didn't want to lie and I knew
there were coming to games who were kind
of falling into that stylistic approach
to comedy and it was really very false
you know they'd kind of be one way
offstage and then kind of fall into this
character on stage and there's nothing
wrong with trying to connect with an
audience but I just didn't want to copy
other people to try to get people to
like me
and you know for a long time I really
struggled and then eventually my tribe
found me but I was able to stay oh now I
sound like a self-help book but like
true to who I was because that was the
only way forward the only way forward as
an artist is to be is to be on the
truthful in the end your work is not
going to be interesting and meaningful
if you are trying to emulate somebody
else or trying to figure out what people
want from you or what they like or
what's popular meaningful art only less
it only connects if it's if it's
authentic and if it comes from euro your
own personal experiences and if and
until you figure that out like what that
is it's never gonna be interesting it's
never going to be good and I always tell
people is not being funny is not really
actually the most important part of
comedy
being truthful is because if someone
sees a good show that guy was really
funny but when you tell the truth about
yourself people go oh my god holy [ __ ]
that guy like spoke to me or about me or
was so vulnerable in that moment like
that was amazing and that's the
difference between good comedy and great
comedy or between good aren't great art
or writing or anything
yeah it's truth that's that's advice
that I've also heard for screenwriting
and many other things it's like yeah
I'm so glad you said that and reminded
me of that
yeah you just have to please your self
period because it might not go your way
anyway but the worst thing is creating
something or I figure out people want
and then creating some piece of [ __ ]
some like crass you know glib solicitous
piece of [ __ ] and people don't buy it
anyway why not make something you love
and then people don't buy at least it
was something that you loved and you're
not embarrassed by it right and you you
said you know it may not work out and if
you're in the creative game at least
from what I've seen particularly in the
beginning most things are not going to
work out yeah right so so you might as
well have one person who's happy about
the process and and I was what I'm
saying about engagement at least the
experience was satisfying and and I
would also I feel like I'm talking too
much I'm gonna I'm gonna stop but the
the the other the other thought I might
underscore for folks that is kind of
practical tactical from a competitive
standpoint if you're trying to place
someone else's game by taking on a
persona
someone who is actually in for instance
in the the def Comedy Jam example that
you give right if somebody's on stage
and they are playing their game that is
who they are you are never going to be
able to take on like the cognitive load
and the fatigue of pretending to be that
type of person and beat someone who is
good at that game you're just not going
to so not here so right yeah you're just
not gonna win so it's like you have you
you will not ultimately in any field
that is competitive which is effectively
every field that people get paid for the
old if you want to be the best
you actually you have to harness your
latent abilities and or you're [ __ ]
like you can't like you mentioned on the
engineering front of me there's so many
places where for instance in writing
it's like I could try to be John McPhee
who writes for The New Yorker or one of
these folks but I can't be those people
I'm not going to be I'm not going to
ever be the wordsmith that say a Tolstoy
was but do I like teaching do i
obsessively think about teaching and
deconstructing things that are complex I
do so I can use books as a medium for
teaching and thinking of it think of it
that way because if I try to be if I try
to out McAfee McAfee I'm gonna get my
face ripped off and you know this is
we're talking about creativity and
creative pursuits which by the way
almost everything is even if you were if
you meet people who are the top of their
game in accounting at the top of the
game I'm not talking about shady money
laundering [ __ ] I'm just saying in
accounting in technology there's an
element there's certainly an element of
creativity if you're looking at the
people who are really at the top and
innovating in any way doing exceptional
work you have done so many different
things acting comedy directing writing
activism you've been a host you've done
voiceover you have you have engaged in
so many different acts of creation I
want to talk about short films films and
so on I want to talk about movies
because as long-term listeners will know
I've been sort of teasing with the idea
which by the way just means
procrastinating of write writing films
and I'm still at step zero and I'm
ashamed of that but no no shame there's
no shame yeah how did how did you decide
to get into film and why I mean films
films
hard why do it it is tough yeah like so
that's a really good question cuz I feel
like there's the you know that like
really humiliating kind of you know clam
about you know well I'm an active what I
really wanted to do is direct and and
and it feels very clichéd I feel like it
was more organic for me because I you
know I again I wasn't someone who kind
of I didn't go to film school and I also
don't think I had the hubris to think
like oh I've done this a cup for a
couple years now I can direct it was I
had written some I love movies like you
know we were talking earlier I was
raised by single dad and you know I was
one of those kids who like I'd go I'd go
with my dad to see like die hard or road
warrior and you know way too early an
age exuberant appropriate you know or
like by the time you know like when I
was in high school I'd seen the
Terminator like the first Terminator
from like twenty or thirty times like I
just loved movies I'd go to the theater
I buy a matinee ticket and I'd stay in
the theater until eight o'clock at night
and I'm just like watched movie after
movie after movie and so it just came
out of a like a real end users love for
film like I was just someone who was
transported by movies and then when I
left talked soup I had been writing on
that show and and like there was a void
and I wrote a script that I was
developing with a with a company and and
I just kept talking about how I thought
it should look and how I thought it
should feel and you know was just so
much more specific than being a writer
and they they were like you know you
should direct this is clearly like a
movie that you should direct and I
hadn't really thought about it but I was
just so intertwined with the material
and what I wanted it to feel like
because I know what I what movies that I
love make me feel like that I wanted
that it's someone who's create that
experience for other people and I just
realized like I didn't I wasn't I
couldn't I didn't know what directing
entailed I didn't have any idea about
what that was gonna be like and I just
went away to and started trying to learn
about directing and so I kind of would
call people that I knew that were
directors if I was working on something
I would ask to come back to set when I
wasn't working so I can hang out and
shadow which is where you just kind of
hang around behind a director and watch
them work and ended up shadow and with
some really incredible people added up
spending several days on the wire and
it's last season and
yeah and just got to just be on the
other side of a process that can be
relatively opaque when you're an actor
you just gotta show up and say your
lines and leave and and then I started
making shorts and I and I guess this is
gonna sound very glib but because I'm
sure I have the resources available to
me that lots of people don't but I do
feel I do believe in it like I just
believe in personal aggression like I
just believe in doing stuff that
personal aggression first impression
like I just believe it like if you want
to make a movie just start making a
movie and I don't mean like go get a
camera start shooting it but what I do
mean is like be be hard on yourself like
learn read learn watch study I think
critically ask questions and then make a
movie and then let it be shitty and then
make another one and let that would be
shitty and keep doing it until you get
better at it like the first short film I
made was and it's an abomination and
will be never see the light of day I had
no idea what I was doing but that did
make me not want to be a director it
just made me realize I needed to learn
more and then I I started to feel like I
was more ready and I was like I need to
make some stuff so first thing was I did
a Comedy Central special and I took the
money that would have been my salary and
I used it to make a like a little short
music video that opens the comedy
special it wasn't anything that was
mandated by the network guys like I want
to do something different so I wrote
this song and I performed it and I made
a music video and and that was like kind
of the first thing I directed I just
used the crew that was already working
on this special and shot this video with
that that's really smart
so I would imagine not not to interject
but you piggybacked on something that
was in your main line of business so to
speak I imagine you saved a lot of costs
by doing that yeah like like the crew
was already gonna come up the day before
and leave the day after to shoot the
special and we'd already rented the
cameras and everything like that but I
had to still had to pay them for the
extra workers took my I took my fee and
I used it to pay everybody else and then
and and then because I didn't have any
more money after that I learned how to
edit and I edited it myself and I
delivered it to the network because I
couldn't afford to pay for additional at
a time and then
after that I thought okay I want to do
more of this so then I I rented a camera
I rented like a can of 5d and I had some
friends were in bands and again like it
sounds fancy but everybody probably
knows somebody who does something you
know just cuz I had some friends were in
a famous band doesn't mean they people
that don't have friends were in bands so
I just called some buddies of mine that
were in bands and I said hey if if you
let me come on tour with you I will make
you a free music video just a piece of
fan art you can use in it however you
like I'm not gonna charge anybody any
money for it but just I want to make
something and I want to make something
for you and so I ended up going on the
road with Silversun Pickups for a couple
of dates and then spending a day with
clutch when they were performing in
Anaheim and then I just gave them I just
cut music videos and delivered it to
them and so then I just started to have
like examples of what I could do why
music videos instead of something else
it just felt like a way to get more
people to see it I had done that first
music video for my Comedy Central
special which was really like a comedic
video but then I was like oh I really
like working in this space and a lot of
directors come out of music video
because you can be kind of radically
creative in that space you don't have
any to have any like narrative linearity
you can experiment you can be radical it
could just be like a series of images
and I also thought well people who like
this band and I love I love this band
will want to see something that about
them it'll be a great way for people to
see something and then hopefully I can
tell a story at the same time so I did
three of those I did a little action
short like I just kind of kept making
stuff in it you know I every time I did
it I learned something every time I did
it I took a bigger risk creatively how
long are these shorts like 3 to 5
minutes 3 to 5 minutes can you think of
any particular lessons that you took
away from any one of those yeah like I
think a lot of it was just skill
building like how do you frame up and
how do you make choices and how do you
do coverage and you know and then how do
you edit like a lot of it was just
really tactical as you would say
practical tactical god I have my pet
phrases this is also my week
and then um and a lot of it was just
caught like just getting confident with
my own ability and and my ability to
articulate what I wanted from other
people you know just how do the other
jobs and asset work who does what what
do I need
oh god this didn't work you know I
didn't work because I didn't have this
kind of a person on set like there were
you know we I was shooting digitally and
then on one show and one of my things
that I shot like we didn't have a like
attack on sunset to like to help me make
sure that it looked the way that I
wanted it to look like that the levels
were set properly so when I got home to
edit it like I had some problems but
like it wasn't they weren't they weren't
catastrophic problems they were just
because because that you know I wasn't
making Star Wars you know I mean I was
just able to be like well this is what
it is and I'm gonna make this and move
on and and then I was getting ready to
do I really wanted to do a feature I
didn't I had some material I'd written
but it was kind of gonna be an expensive
movie but I was still shadowing so I had
a friend who had a show called penny
dreadful I love John Logan to create a
penny truffle I met him at Comic Con Ed
hosted the panel for that show and he
was like hey why do you love the show
you should come visit us in Ireland and
I remember thinking like to myself
people always say that and you always
say yeah then you never do it as Ike I'm
gonna do it I'm [ __ ] going to Ireland
man that's I'm gonna be cool I'm gonna
be a cool kid for once in my life and
and so I ended up going over visiting
penny dreadful and Vikings shot right up
the road so I got them to let me visit
that set I just hung out I'm like passed
out sandwiches and you know lifted stuff
and asked questions and watch the work
and and then while I was over there I
met a bunch of Irish actors and and and
one of them two of them actually one was
it was a was an actor composer one was a
writer a screenwriter and an actor and
we ended up making a short film together
in Ireland at the end of 2014 that was
my first narrative short my first kind
of story driven short and it was it was
just great it was just like I was like
oh this is like totally Who I am this is
what I want to do with my life where did
you film in Ireland in in a in Galway
which is the powerful town that's yes
such a great place there for a month
in 2005 oh yeah credible
it's Festival there it's a really
beautiful spot yeah it is it's like it's
it's like the arts center of Ireland you
know they've got a beautiful film
festival in the summer they've got our
arts festival
you know like local theatres and it was
just a great experience and you know
things went wrong and things went right
but you know we got it in the can in
three days and it was just super cool
and personal and then that same writer
who had written that short had a feature
he'd already written and he asked me if
I wanted to take a look at it and it was
just a perfect first film and that
that's the film that became access okay
so I I want to dig in to access but
before we get to that you're taking
these trips doing these music videos
during that period are you did you save
up for that period noting knowing that
you would need to work out of your
savings are you depending on royalties
and other streams to pay your bills
how are you covering the necessities of
life as you're handing out sandwiches
and doing all these various things
well it wasn't it wasn't as prolonged of
a period as it sounds like I was on
hiatus so like I was I was working on I
was working on the talk at the time and
we got a month off every year so I went
in that month but I think if I was
talking to a layperson who didn't work
in television I would I would say like
you know if if what you want is to grow
in whatever field you're interested in
like just create a space for that like
you know make that your vacation yeah
like I didn't wasn't like I like was
like riding around in a limousine like I
just flew over and I hung around you
know for like a week and watch people
work and it wasn't any more or less
burdensome than taking a vacation but I
but one thing I was more interested in
doing as I got older and we started with
this in the beginning it's like you said
it I know and I I think we kind of went
past it but it's so interesting to me it
was I just I was more I just really
wanted more discomfort in my life I I
was like you know it's very easy the
older you get to be like you know get in
car go to work eat bag lunch get in car
go to gym
go home eat food watch TV go to bed and
then you just think like am i growing it
like it's like any of this interesting
am I gonna have one life and I'm just
spending it in this like torpor and so
for that I was going to a place where I
mean I knew I knew one guy at petty
dreadful but I didn't know anybody at
this other show and I just kind of cold
called them and said you know kind of
kind of come visit and they were super
gracious what I'm so curious to
interrupt you yet again what is that he
what does that email say it says hi and
again I understand that maybe this is
gonna feel a little rarefied hi I'm an
American actress I've worked on these
shows I'm just I'm sad I've been
shadowing to direct for a long time I
would be really grateful if I could come
and visit your show for a few days and
shadow and I will be as unobtrusive and
and and invisible as I possibly can and
I'll be here these days and and you know
I understand if you can't accommodate me
but I really be grateful and I think it
helped in my particular case because I
had tweeted a lot about how much I loved
Vikings so they kind of knew that I was
a big fan of the show and I and I did
some tweeting from said you know I kind
of I kind of like paid my way and in in
in you know like flacking their show for
them but which can I just - I I I'm not
over caffeinated I swear to god I'm just
you're making you're making so many
import points that I just want to pause
and help well as much for myself as
anyone else just people to reflect on so
what you did in terms of tweeting people
might say well I don't have a verified
account and nobody's going to pay
attention to one tweet in the Twitter
feed of 10,000 if it's a popular TV show
but I can tell you from personal
experience that you could for instance
write something for a medium or for film
the blank outlet that has a high Google
another in other words page rank and
- and that many of the producers actors
and so on will have Google Alerts or
other alerts set that deliver to their
inboxes relevant media that mentioned
say the show or the actors and you do
not need to be a famous actress or an
author or any of those things to do do
is work at the highest possible caliber
of quality that you can I mean I think
you also touched on this about the idea
that people are like more interest in
being expeditious than they are and
being good I think that you know that
this holds very very true for this
business a lot of people have gotten
have made headway because they did
something that nobody saw but when they
when people asked them what they did the
thing they were able to show was
extraordinary and I don't mean like
expensive extraordinary I just mean
unique and personal and crafted with
care and so if that's something that you
wrote or if it's something that you made
if you made you know the the number of
time een this is not the best example
but it's a good one 20 years ago there
was this video tape going around
Hollywood of these guys in an apartment
and it was VHS tape that's how long ago
it was and people were dubbing it and
sending and giving to friends of these
guys in apartment these three black guys
we're the one guy goes up and it's the
little intercom it goes was I and then
there was a the third guy that was a
short film that some guy made on like a
digital camera none of them were famous
they were just some guys in New York
that ended up being that Budweiser
campaign that's crazy I had no idea that
was the origin it was a short film it
wasn't it was it was a two-and-a-half
minute short film that was just funny
you didn't know who was it you didn't we
didn't know these guys no one knew who
they were and and they didn't have any
connections and I think it was just
about doing something that felt original
and personal and I get it just comes
back to like don't try to figure out
people want just do what's interesting
and important to you and then keep doing
it until you come up with something
extraordinary and that will be your
calling card and may not happen as fast
as you want or as aggressively as you
honor as expansive as you want but in
the meantime you're doing cool [ __ ]
which should be your primary goal in any
event you know when I made
honestly I just wanted to make a movie
to show people I could make a movie I
wanted to make the best movie I could
and I was very rigorous in leveraging
the resources that I had to the best of
my ability but I I don't know that I had
a lot of expectation that a lot of
people would see it it's just because I
made the best movie I could that you
know it got all of this attention but
but I don't think I was going in my this
is gonna be a massive hit I was like I'm
gonna make this little movie and then to
the next one when people say well what
have you done I could be like look at
this little thing I made you know so I
think you have to always be focused on
the results not the result on the thing
and not the result because the result is
directly tied to the quality of the
thing so it's not about being familiar
your work so just be doing excellent
[ __ ] all the time and eventually one of
those things will connect with other
people yeah not to sound like a fortune
cookie on top of all of that but like
the the only uncrowded market is great
like there's always a [ __ ] market for
great and to like like be radically
great like don't be like I saw ten
things like this let me do the eleven
thing like be brave enough to court
failure that's probably when you're
going to do something great absolutely
and if you get if you are really in love
with something I'll give two examples if
you're really in love with say
screenplays and film or if you're really
in love and passionate about maybe it's
a better word possessed by right
technology investing early-stage
technology investing on two phenomena
two companies at this point certainly
that are worth looking at and just
investigating the stories of demonstrate
very clearly what you can do if you are
just rejected by the establishment or if
you want to not operate within the
existing power structure to it so the
two examples are the blacklist look up
Franklin Leonard and the blacklist
absolutely and then the second is and we
don't have to get into both these right
now the second is just by coincidence
also has the list at the end but angel
list and navall rava Khan and people can
look up
the ever while the avenging angel was
the title of his interview in his alumni
magazine at Dartmouth in fact
but I get excited when I when I hear
these types of stories so they should
check them out and this is let's come
back to let's come back to axis know
what is axis and did you did you have
anybody try to talk you out of doing
such a good question well hmm so axis is
a thriller about about an expatriate
Irish actor living in Los Angeles who
has had a lot of success kind of
explosive success in his youth and has
really just used all of his resources to
just wreck his life you know he's a
drunk then he's a drug addict and he's
sterile relationships and stick to
everybody and and and when we when we
meet him he's trying to turn his life
around and and it and it's really about
a guy who's not a bad person but he's
done some bad stuff which I think almost
every human being can relate to you know
I mean we all we all have a little bit
of a demon inside of us and I think this
is just a guy who's been he's he's he's
been frail in the past but he's really
trying to be a better version of himself
but slowly over the course of an
afternoon and the movie takes place in
real time as he's driving to Los Angeles
his his life starts to unravel and it's
really about him trying to hold things
together trying to be a better person
trying to be a better person his
relationships with his family with
people that he works with just trying to
try to be better it's really dark it's
very funny and IIIi have been thinking
I'm sure I'll get some letters about
this but I happen to find that addicts
are really entertaining people and I
don't mean they're funny like like laugh
at them I I find that they that
typically people who are who have broke
who broken themselves down are just more
honest than people who are trying to be
perfect all the time and so you know
he's just he's he's a guy who's
self-aware he's wherever the mistakes
he's made so it's a very darkly fun
movie and it's very twisty it's a it's a
thriller so it's got a lot of secrets
and it the most unique aspect that the
movies that the whole thing takes place
in real time inside a car as he's
driving to Los Angeles so the the lead
actor is the only actor on screen and
all the other actors are our voice
actors on the phone with him what was
your how would you describe your
experience of being involved with this
film I was so wonderful you asked if
people tried to dissuade me from doing
it and the short answer is in in
Hollywood the way that people dissuade
you from doing stuff is just by not do
not helping you you don't even get no
you just get like silence but but this
happened very quickly so I didn't have a
traditional kind of like discouraging
period of frustration with trying to put
this movie together because I read it in
like September August or September of
2015 and I was kind of at peak
engagement at the time in terms of work
like I was on four shows and I really
only had a little bit of time off in
2016 and I realized if I didn't make the
movie and this one single week in in May
of 2016 that I wasn't gonna be able to
make it at all in that year and I have
to push to the next year and so then it
just became about hitting that target
like how can I hit this target so I
never even went like the traditional way
of trying to find like people to finance
the movie in a studio because they were
gonna say like we don't know this actor
is like he's unknown can you even
somebody famous in this role can it be
Ryan Gosling and then can it not be with
just him on camera can we have other
actors in the movie and then can we make
it not in a car can you make it like
we're just gonna you know the whole kind
of concept of the film was gonna unravel
you know it's very typical in Hollywood
where people are service converse that
they take all of the edge and and and
like singularity at our project so very
quickly I realized that I was gonna have
to probably crowdfund the movie if I
wanted to do it my way
and on my time on my timeframe so and
about in in in March of 2016 I had my
like first exploratory conversation with
like the people around me and with
Kickstarter I was able to you know they
have people over there who are kind of
like around to like help you kind of
figure out how to put a project together
I built the campaign in three weeks I
long
in April and one of the rules about
crowdfunding and Kickstarter
specifically it's not a hard and fast
rule it's not I can rule that they
enforce but it's just like a rule of
thumb that if you raise half of your
money in the first week he'll probably
fund fully so we had raised half of our
money in that first week and then I
started hiring people on the film and we
really we didn't raise a lot of money
for a feature was about two hundred
thousand dollars that we raised and so
that was what we had to make the movie
and so originally it was we were gonna
make it nine days but I realized if I
made it faster I'd have more money
available to me like daily I haven't
like my daily resource load would be
higher so we cut the schedule from nine
days to seven days which is incredibly
aggressive for a future whenever I tell
people I made it in seven days they ask
well how is it a short but so we had to
be really aggressive so everything we
know we ended up doing it in this way
that was so terrifying and so breakneck
but so exhilarating which is that we
shot the first 15 pages of the movie in
the first day and then we shot the next
65 pages of the movie it was actually
us-- at about 17 pages in the first date
about 67 pages on day two through seven
and that meant that the actor had to do
67 pages of dialogue day and for people
that don't know typically on a movie you
do like between three and six pages of
dialogue a day so he was essentially
doing the entire movie all the way
through every day locked in a hot car
with no air-conditioning and in in May
at the beginning of June essentially in
Los Angeles and it was just so intense
but we shot three cameras so by day
three we essentially had the entire
movie in the can because you know we
were doing the whole thing all the way
through from three angles so by day two
we had six angles and we had the whole
movie on on you know not on wax on the
digital version of wax and so then the
next four days were just about kind of
creative play and and I think that what
the result is is this I made a movie in
a week it's experimental it's unusual it
it's transporting and strange
and going in I thought I'll never make a
movie this way again but now I would
make a movie that way again because um I
just didn't have any time to be to be
afraid or feel that there was no time to
be to be anxious I just had to go it was
really it was it was wonderful it was it
was like one of the seminal experiences
of my life
there's definitely some magic in the
ether when you have a hyper aggressive
deadline there's just something that
happens to the space-time continuum and
what you can achieve yeah
when everything gets compressed that in
this please
certain things just come to the surface
like certain things are thrown into
relief and it's not like you can't make
mistakes but I think you get a clarity
sometimes because you can't dither right
you can't you can't there's there's no
time for paralysis by analysis I am
making this decision I'm making it
definitively it may be the wrong one but
I'm going to lean all the way into it
and we're gonna see what happens
and also because we shot the whole movie
all the way through if there were errors
I had the next day to recalibrate in a
way that you don't get when you
typically make a movie for people again
who don't know I kind of like I'm you
know I'm an actor as well so like when
I'm on a TV show or I'm doing a movie or
whatever I'll leave at the end of the
day gosh [ __ ] man I wish I'd done this
with that scene I wish I tried this but
every day the next day we got to wake up
and go you know what we have a whole new
bite at this Apple we're gonna do it a
whole different way today and so at the
end I really felt like we really fully
explored the material which would not
have we wouldn't have been able to do if
we were making movie in seven days and
not doing it like with this kind of
volume approach that we had so I'm
looking at text in a book that you
contributed to happens to be this is it
try to amend this fantastic book oh let
me see here it is for the for those of
you who get that for those of you who
get the what about Bob reference there's
this groundbreaking new book oh yes here
it is and there's an entire shelf of the
therapist on book
Richard driving cinetic is the the
question to what you would put on a
gigantic billboard metaphorically
speaking to get a message to millions or
billions of people in this case what you
selected was a Jack Canfield quote
everything you want is on the other side
of fear and many of the stories that
you've told so far illustrate that
certainly what what are you afraid of
now or what fear are you hoping say in
the next year to get on the other side
of does anything come to mind
hmm that's a good question well you know
it's interesting cuz like I think like
the one that feels the most obvious is
like I'm afraid I won't get to make
another film but I I'm not really
legitimately afraid of that because I
feel like I'm just gonna put this next
movie together if I get like hey like if
I didn't know that one like no help and
no assistance from anybody like the next
one's gonna be cake I mean I had help I
had my team but I didn't have the kind
of traditional Hollywood help right like
a team I like agents kind of you know
making magic like it was really just
like a scrappy little group of
filmmakers you know doing this film with
me the lead actor and screenwriter and
and and and my creative executives it
was a small group of people you know
outside completely outside of the system
but am I afraid of God that's so really
good and then it's not that I'm fearless
it it may just be that the things that
are interesting to me now don't engender
fear the way that they used to I can
also I can also I think tackle this from
a different angle which is what do you
currently what is one of your greatest
struggles right now what do you struggle
with if anything you know my main
struggle is just always look being as
effective as I want to be you know I
mean I'm just super ambitious I have
like highly developed I don't mean like
I'm good at it I mean like it's like
very far advanced like workaholism I
mean like like I have pathological
workaholism it's it's like a sickness
and when I tell whenever I say I'm a
workaholic people always laugh and I go
like it's a problem you know I don't
know how to rest I don't I don't it's
it's not that I don't like to play I do
like play but like I don't think I have
any time to rest and and I worry that it
makes me it it could result in me not
being an interesting artist because I
think you need to play into daydream and
to rest and to experience things to be
able to tell interesting stories you
know no one wants to hear about you know
your daily Trek from your home to your
office it's just not compelling I
remember you know I think it was Amanda
Palmer said this I apologize to ever
said it if I miss tributing but the
Amanda Palmer creative musician
extraordinaire and she said you know I
think it was her who said in order to
have she married to Neil Gaiman she is
yeah yeah exactly
for those of you and after me no yep
yeah I will I will bow at the feet of
Neil Gaiman writer and everybody should
listen to his audiobook of the graveyard
book narrated by him he is also the most
soothing voice imaginable but I digress
what the [ __ ] was I saying yes that you
know if life if art imitates life in
order to create art you have to have a
life right yeah absolutely and like and
I'm paraphrasing that's butchered you
know I'm sure there are other theories
there's a there's a very famous French
writer it's not south but it's uh it's
somebody anyway about like have a
bourgeois life and be radical in your
work but I actually don't think I
actually think that you you need to be
fully engaged in your life in order to
be an interesting artist because you
know you need to be alive to be able to
speak about the human condition so if so
if you have if you have advanced early
onset workaholism right you've you've
really turned this into a default mode
what do you know are you doing anything
to to try to
and manage that or create more slack in
the system for the daydreaming and so on
I mean it's like that's my daily
practice that's my like that's my one
day at a time you know it's like just
constantly trying to remind myself to
rest I am Cait socially a lot more than
I used to I I so see you made out in the
real world yeah look out the real world
I could go out and I and I you know I
try to not just be like you know I just
had a period of life where I was just
like up gym work sleep you know and just
I just remember one day I was like I'm
gonna die
like that I'm gonna I'm gonna die of
boredom I'm boy I bore myself you know
what I mean and so you know like I I
think I try to court danger in a safe
way it's not like I'm jumping on a plane
with no parachute or bullfighting or you
know bare-knuckle brawl in an alley you
know filled with needles but I but I am
trying to just like be be not always
have my head in my computer but but look
the reason that people are workaholics
well there's lots of reasons I'm sure
social pressures but for me I just get
this big like serotonin release says
it's serotonin what's the brain what's
the satisfaction dopamine perhaps
dopamine serotonin sleepy sleepy time
yeah dopamine I get a dopamine release
when I when I complete tasks and I just
you know I get I get higher and higher
the more that I execute I find executing
in and of itself really enjoyable so I'm
just trying to apply that aggression to
like like leisure like can I get the
same satisfaction from image if I if I
if I make it to do list and one of them
things does have fun well I get the same
dopamine release if I have a lot of fun
how can I turn fun into work most
effectively [ __ ] crushed by to do
this but you know I I realized that like
I I even though I can feel very harried
it's interesting to me to be feeling
like a part of being on this planet is
like fully engaging and doing everything
I can do and everything I'm interested
in and because I don't want to look back
and be like man I should have tried that
I'm
you look back and say man I tried that
and it went terribly for me that's a
that's a perfectly comfortable space for
me to be like man I try that and I
should completely [ __ ] the bed but but
what I find very uncomfortable is the
idea that I I always wanted to do
something and I never did it and so
that's what I fear what I fear is what I
fear is not is not trying not
experiencing all the things that I want
to experience how do you think you know
yeah how do you think your life because
you you have you live so aggressively
you milk the most out of the hours that
you have how would you or your life be
different if you didn't have exercise as
an element do you think well it's
interesting because I really I really
love working out but there's a constant
battle for me between like being
effective like with work and like you
know I I'm the queen of like getting up
at like 5:00 a.m. to work out putting on
my workout clothes and then being in
front of my computer at 4 o'clock in the
afternoon and I haven't moved like I
mean that's just like my that's just a
normal day like didn't move didn't eat
and do anything just been in front of
the computer for like 11 hours but it
just it's just such a great stress
manager and I also think that there's
another thing there which is it just
again like puts you back in your body
you know this like thing that's carrying
your brain around and making you
effective and you know I'm I think that
with everything that all of the stimulus
that we stimuli that we experience
nowadays all the pictures and the images
of perfection that are coming in at a
much faster and more voluminous pace
it's really easy to fall into like it's
like an abusive relationship with with
exercise either doing it so much that
you know you're hurting yourself or not
doing it and then engaging that inner
monologue about how you're like
worthless and you can't get you [ __ ]
together and I I don't have either of
those things I just know I'm happier and
better when I work out but I don't I
don't I don't do I've finally dropped
the monologue about like you know I'm
like I'm not a good person if I don't
like if I don't crush a workout I just
try to do it every day
I know I'm better mentally and I also
cheat completely like I have my father
took a hike today you know I had my
phone with me and like I stopped every
10 minutes like write something down you
know I'm not really like folios I'm not
being in the moment when I'm working out
a lot of times I'm stopping like
hundreds of times to make notes and
remind myself of stuff I have to do or
put stuff on my calendar do you still
use concept - or a rowing machine I
still use my odometer my constituent
gamma tur I have had it since 2000 it is
18 years old I've never had to repair it
or replace any parts it's it's the best
it's the single best piece of equipment
that I have my whole gym now I have my
whole gym in my place I have a TRX
bodyweight system I have two kettlebells
a 25 and a 35 I have my or gamma tur I
have battle ropes that are attached to
my dining room table and I have one big
power step that I just used to do like
pistols and stuff like that and I get
everything done with those five things
that is fantastic so pistols for glued
oh no those are one-legged squats and
they can be very very difficult
depending on how you go about it
answer a step can help you because it
could just kind of do like single leg
step downs until you build up your your
quad and you're good strength to do
crystals what could you describe for us
a recent workout or what a prototypical
workout of yours might look like um well
I I hike today that was just like a 90
minute hike it which was just more about
like feeling groovy but right now I'm
obsessed with my ergometer I like I kind
of go through periods of like mountain
rowing and then periods of rowing really
aggressively and this is this is gonna
be right up your alley Tim I'm ready
it's racist this is like centered this
is like bullseye for you and your
audience I started going to a naturopath
so I'd be like supplementing differently
and I started taking glutathione and I'm
rowing like faster now than I did in my
20s like I just keep getting personal
bests on my bro right so it's confusing
I'm a lot older than that well I'm a lot
older than I was when I was running
competitively and I just keep like
knocking like 30 seconds and then 45
seconds and then a minute and 10 seconds
off my rowing time so now I'm just
obsessed with like hitting personal
bests every time I row okay let's dig
into this yeah
glutathione how is it for those who
aren't familiar glutathione is thought
of a simple way to think of it or the
way it's often described as a master
antioxidant of sorts
how are you having administered as it
being so inside baseball sometimes I get
IVs I get IVs if I really like if I'm
wrecked like if I travel a lot or I went
to Coachella and is that is that pure is
that is that is that pure is that just
glutathione or are you doing that at the
vitamins I could do at the end in my IV
I'll get like B vitamins like you know
and a glutathione push at the end yeah
exactly but you can get you can get like
fat saw you looking at this like fat
soluble goodness I on that you just take
you just like gulp down just like axle
grease yeah is this what is this company
uh light but it's lipo spheric that's
the name like the spherical if I because
before the Gulf I and I was rowing slow
and now I'm just like a jackrabbit so it
could be something else but I'm gonna
I'm gonna say it's the glutathione I
will warn people in advance I had some
of this life is live aspheric buddha
found at won't play and I gave it to a
friend of mine and I think it might have
been for those who know my buddy Kevin
Rose since I like to mention him even
miss tribute things to him just for fun
I think I gave him one and he said
something like what is this horse semen
it does have a weird has a very weird
consistency in me this axle grease yeah
cause I gave it to my dad I was like I
think this would really help you and and
you're supposed to take it and liquid
but he's just been eating on a spoon
he's up he's up he's a better man than I
oh I just like squeegee it out of the
little packet I take it I take it with
like about two like two ounces of
kombucha in the morning so I don't have
to think about it yeah but you like I
think so I mean you're sure you're like
this or maybe maybe after all of that
experimentation on yourself you just get
up and have a bowl of like frosty flakes
in the Mornington but you know it's like
I do that if I have my bowl of
supplement so that I have my fish oil
then I have my curcumin and I
my turmeric by the end of the morning
like I I've just I've supplemented it's
like a banquet like I don't even need to
eat I've taken so many crappy tablets
okay just to just hit pause again so
that you is the exercise before
breakfast is it the first thing you do
what is your first ideal morning what's
the first 90 minutes 60 to 90 minutes
look like a special shot glutathione
what time what time do you wake up
depends on the day like you know between
like 6:00 and 7:00 okay pick a bladder
earlier but I love one of my shows go so
I don't have to wake up the crack of
dawn every day anymore so it's like
between like you know like 6:00 and 7:00
o'clock and then I have to work out in
the morning I won't wake up
you have espresso shot mm-hmm
glutathione with I always have coffee
before I work out like without fail and
then the glutathione with the kombucha
any particular type of kombucha that's
your preferred axle-grease mixer yeah I
like better Booch and I like was it life
aid I think is one of the other
I love kombucha I'm just I'm veremos I'm
very [ __ ] when it comes to come Booch
alright so then then you then you buckle
down to workout and I this is gonna
sound like I'm just looking for
opportunity to plug which maybe I am but
the you describe your work the one of
your workouts the concept to like
mid-distance 5k rows punctuated by short
distance to K hit Sprint's
high-intensity interval training or yeah
hi intestinal training with with a 10k
long distance row once or twice a week
is that would that be a current workout
yeah that's typically my workouts and
then I'll do like I'll do like like a
set of five five by 25 kettlebells
that's like you know like I'll get up
one morning just 225 kettlebell swings
in front of the television and and
sometimes I'll do a TRX workout because
I didn't have really a way to simulate
pull-ups
so that was like that was why I got the
TRX so I could do that was like the one
thing I didn't have and here was a
pull-up bar is the TRX attached to it
to add or is it - yes it's like a
railing like I have like a like a
upstairs railing and it just hangs off
of the railing got it yeah and that's it
I mean I tried I tried
like relatively simple so that'll do it
um I don't really train with anybody
because I just can't I can't I can
manage the our work out but I can't
manage the the transit between a mice
home and ifs I don't have enough time to
do that too you know what I mean like
I've got the hour I don't have two hours
so I just I don't go to a gym anymore
because I just I just would be I
wouldn't have the time for it the other
transit time that yeah transit time was
what killed me you know it's like I have
an hour to work out but I don't have a
half hour on either side of that to go
to the gym do you still watch shows when
you row totally what do you watch what
do you would any any recent favorites
what are you watching currently just
like fantastic junk I mean some good
stuff like I love I watch The Walking
Dead fear The Walking Dead that's always
really good workout shows all right now
I'm watching The Magicians but during my
workouts and then when I finished that
what will i watch after that sometimes I
watch stuff that's on streaming services
because I hate to have to when I'm
rowing I don't want to have to watch
commercials and I can't stop to
fast-forward because I'm trying to beat
my previous row time so like a little
stream lick stream stuff on Hulu like X
Files or Handmaid's Tale or I just
watched the show called Deutschland 83
that was pretty great it has to be
something that I can kind of watch which
is why I'll typically watch something
that's like not too mentally demanding
you know so I don't I can't I can't pay
attention too closely to plot points do
you make new year's resolutions do you
have any routines or rituals around New
Year's we're talking just for people who
may be listening to this at another time
we're chatting at the end of March
mm-hmm like Nick hey Kenny this year
right I make the same one every year
would just arrest more it's the same
resolution every arrest so how are you
gonna do that this time
I don't know I should just give up I
should stop making resolutions and I
won't have to have not nothing I mean
look maybe maybe maybe a part of success
or like like success at being you like
figuring out being you is like
understanding what your strengths and
your weaknesses are you know like my
strength is my strength is is my
aggressive work ethic
and it was went out like when I was a
young comic I would be like oh I should
be writing everyday I should write I
should be like this guy well like that's
just not my that's just not how I
operate so I think once you accept like
what your own this is why you know this
is why you watch The Terminator 30 times
yes you're like this this is my people
right personality but like once you
accept like this is my how these are my
strengths this is where I excel this is
how I excel rather than try to force
yourself into someone else's like
workflow like figure out what yours is
you know I as a writer and and and you
written lots of books I've only written
two but with both books I had this huge
lead time and it wasn't that I was lazy
or procrastinating like the book wasn't
there yet and then just one day the book
was there and then I sat down and I
wrote the entire book in a few weeks but
it just needed to gel it needed to
synthesize and if I had been trying to
sit down and kind of write a little bit
every day what did you spend like this
like big agglomeration of glop but just
one day I was like oh the book is in it
the book is in me now the book is in me
and then I got it out you know god I
wish that I wish I had that experience
man of so jelly everybody's different
yeah like a long time I would have
wanted to be more like you like
disciplined and sitting down and because
you know there's there's there's a panic
that didn't Suze when you are seven
weeks when your deadline and you had
nine months to write a book thing but
it's just like that for me certain
threads have to connect and that
requires like rumination and time and
and you know I can't just can't do it
any other way so I don't I think I think
my strength is eating every day trying
to eat a wheelbarrow full of glass and
[ __ ] out diamonds or something like that
well speaking of eating glass so what I
was this is this this mate might be
predictable but I'm okay with
predictable I would like to start to
wrap up with a handful of questions and
the first one I'm going to ask is and
you actually give people a head a heads
up on this but the self inflicted wounds
so you usually say at some point I'm
going to ask you about X but I'm
you've had time to think about this so
do you have any favorite stories of
self-inflicted wounds of your own that
you could share obviously the book is
just a collection not even a
comprehensive one but but but quite
detailed of many many mistakes that I've
made I'm trying to think of something
that's happened recently it's it's
interesting I see my mistakes
differently now than I did when I was
younger they just feel like an aspect of
being human versus like some kind of
tragic why exactly they just it just
seemed like an unavoidable aspect of
being alive and I'm trying to think if
there's if there's one way and then I'm
thinking ones that recently that don't
feel like that cataclysmic so them like
they're like a lame like lame stories oh
you could pick a classic also like the
the greatest hits like if you're
watching TV fifteen years ago and it's
like hits from the 80s we could we could
take one of those as well
oh god good thinkin thinkin thinkin
again it's interesting like I was
talking about that short film that I
made that that was like the one that
will never be seen by any human being I
actually I think it's been destroyed
where it was just like I just thought
that I could just charm my way to this
short and I had a bunch of friends kind
of show up and it was such an odd it was
such an odd idea it didn't make any
sense it was about a guy who flashed
women and he flashed women and I can't
remember why he flashed women but it was
something to do with like bravery it was
like a metaphor for bravery that this
guy would like flash women and and also
maybe like like hubris like the idea
that like people are gonna be super
excited to see this guy's penis and he
would kind of like try to use it as
currency you know whatever kind of go
his way but it just made no sense it
just ended up being like a series have
been yet about a guy like reeling his
penis straight I just remember at the
end like literally thinking it's one
thing to think like people don't get me
I was like I don't get myself
[Laughter]
and it was it just never ever coalesced
but but it was it was fine because it
was like I remember kind of enjoying the
process of making it and then being
really kind of surprised and delighted
by what a piece of [ __ ] it was much like
that set where nobody laughed I thought
well man that didn't work at all okay go
back and figure out what to do next
and I think like I think every artist
you know I think when Tarantino has a
famous story about his first shown being
unwatchable you know I think I just
think you know sometimes if your
personality is to be really aggressive
and kind of dive in you're bound you're
bound to make some spectacular failures
you know and and you just have to have a
high tolerance for that and and and not
take it personally and keep moving
forward but yeah I literally was like I
know you guys don't get it I don't get
it I don't know I can't explain it to
you no I thank you for putting
yourselves in my hands it was a terrible
mistake on your part trusted me with
your lives what is what's the name of
the shirt it was called the whipper
conjures all sorts of images when have
you been extremely proud of yourself
could be any point in your life can you
can you think of a standout point where
you're like I got a goddamn like good
for me fucking-a I hate I hate to have
it be about this because it sounds like
it's super self emotional but I really
am proud of this film and I for a
variety reasons I think because it did
it did actually
what's yeah access because it was such a
I mean I was lucky that I was brought a
great script and I had a really talented
actor but we we put this movie together
like so quickly and I knew and I had a
vision for it but I also was because we
were moving so fast feeling my way it's
too dark in some aspect and I think one
of the reasons why it it came together
the way that it did was because I was I
was both I both had a vision for the
film but I was open to modulating and I
think that's really important in
anything that you're doing no matter
what field you're in is that you have to
both we reprise vision and kind of
rigidity and this in this culture but I
think that
being able to pivot and be nimble is way
more important than being kind of a
rigid visionary you have to be able to
look at data and interpret it and then
apply it to your situation or you just
you're just gonna keep banging your head
against a wall so you know we made this
movie we we got into the ferry first
second day of filming we start really
late we lost our light we had to kind of
pivot that day I ended up having a throw
that footage away another day we lost
light and had to get back up at 5:00 in
the morning kind of shoot dawn for dusk
but we just kept pivoting we just kept
nothing was catastrophic okay like and I
think that's something I got for my
father it's like okay this isn't working
okay so we're gonna do this okay that's
not working we're gonna do this rather
than oh my god this is the end of the
world what are we gonna do and then in
post I had very little money proposed in
very little time to cut the movie
together and and about four weeks in the
editor that I had cutting the movie he
was a great guy really talented just
wasn't connecting with the material
wasn't wasn't able to assemble the movie
it was an unusual movie it's one guy in
a car and I I had to let him go and then
I had to learn avid they have a system
and start cutting the movie myself but
again I wasn't like what I'm gonna do I
don't know I'm gonna die I said okay
well like the answer here is that I'm
gonna learn this skill set and I'm going
to keep moving forward and then you know
I made this little film it was seen a
strange and Atmospheric and dreamlike
and you know it didn't get into Sundance
and everybody else wants to get into
Sundance but then it got into eight
other festivals and won two awards and
got picked up for distribution and the
result has been much better than I ever
could have anticipated and and I'm
really proud of it because I mean I made
made it for what is typically the
catering budget on a regular Hollywood
movie you know what I mean we made it
for just no money and in no time and and
I think it also says something I think
what I'm also proud of is that the movie
actually does have a strong point of
view and a strong visual personality and
a strong style that is my own when I
look at it I don't think I'm trying to
emulate anybody I feel like this is this
is something that I made it's my it's my
little lumpy ashtray from shop class and
I really love it good for you and it's
you know I there there's this I think
it's easy to not not I'm not saying you
but for humans to look at the people who
are showcased on the covers of magazines
or on the front pages of popular
websites and think wow they figured out
all the secret sauce or they have the
keys to the kingdom and they're able to
show up and just hit home runs every
time they step to the plate and when you
look at the origin stories of some of
these incredible creations that people
are familiar with whether it's jaws or
company alibaba's one example Jack Ma
the founder I think he's the richest man
in China certainly one of the top few at
this point and he said paraphrasing but
we had a huge advantage in the beginning
and that was we had no experience no
money and no plan and it forces you to
really think outside of the box and even
if that project doesn't succeed by
outside measures the confidence that you
develop in exploring areas outside of
the box can then transfer to future
projects a more there's this fantastic
documentary get a butcher's name it well
it's fantastic mostly for the message
not for all of the content which I hope
makes sense but it's called the Yoda
were skis dune and it's the story of
this attempt to make a movie about dune
and the thing is a complete unmitigated
disaster like completely under the gate
disaster but the the the talent that was
assembled went on to just do incredible
things and if that disaster hadn't
happened one could argue that if you if
you had stepped on that butterfly these
other careers wouldn't have lost him do
in the way that they did and you
wouldn't have the geiger design of the
alien that people now know as the alien
of aliens and so on so it's I just love
this no one ever learns from success I
mean you you can kind of you can kind of
do a post-mortem and say oh this stuff
worked but failure is where is where you
have explosive growth where you really
have to reconsider all of your
assumptions and and it's it's so much
more powerful than successes at making
you eventually successful so aggressive
aggr that's that's that's my life
philosophy be aggressive be aggressive
and we want you around for a long time
so take your cat naps at the very least
and I do you have anything you would
like to say or ask of the audience
suggestions you'd like to make anything
at all that you'd like to to say before
we wrap up other than watch your
business exactly that's interesting I
mean I mean I guess like I like when I
when I did my podcast you know like
somatically the stuff that we've talked
about was always stuff that I talked
about which is like it doesn't matter
what your what you want to do like you
know and again and it sounds very
greeting-card but like the barriers are
their imagined you know I mean and and
and maybe you're gonna have to start
small and maybe we're going to start
close to home but like the the greater
regret will always be not having started
and this it's I'm always trying to find
a way to be more bold in my life and
hopefully share the things that have
helped me do that with other people so
it is exciting to be having the
conversation with you because I think
that's a lot of what you've done is
you've kind of you know live these
experiences so that the things that you
learn could be shared with other people
and it's you know just go out and do
awesome [ __ ] get your hands dirty
tonight the the the rough drafts are not
a clean business
absolutely not
Asia thank you so much for taking the
time so much fun I know super fun and
now that I know where you are
I will track you down the next time I'm
in your neck of the woods yeah barbecue
music whatever it might be and in Austin
Texas come visit and people can visit
you is the best best site Aisha Tyler
calm yeah calm but you know who spends
time on a website anymore just follow me
on twitter facebook instagram all that
stuff is just Aisha Tyler one word a sh
a t yl ER absolutely absolutely and
everyone I'm sorry you're gonna say
something sis gonna I don't know this is
gonna post but I post stuff about all
the stuff I'm doing the movies out on
the 10th of April on video demand iTunes
all that stuff and then Archer starts I
think on the 24th of April and oh the
other side oh no TV whatever you can
find me online I don't know when you're
gonna listen to this but you know just
come say hi to me on social cinema for
days and weeks and months and years and
millennia to come hopefully we'll be
listening to the cockroaches remember us
fondly and for you non cockroaches
actually if cockroach is listening
you're welcome also to check out the
show notes where I will provide links to
everything that we've talked about
including access and you can find all of
those at Tim dot blog forward slash
podcast along with show notes for every
other episode and I should thank you so
much one more time for being so goddamn
entertaining and inspiring at the same
time it's a rare combo so really
appreciate thanks of course and to
everybody out there on the interwebs be
safe maybe me it more important be
aggressive get out there if you've if
you're dreaming of doing something
creating something someday
just get out a shitty first draft
because guess what all the first wraps
are really [ __ ] awful it's very rare
that's
just as I was alluding to shits out
diamonds on a daily basis it's it starts
with putting something out there into
the world and hopefully at least it
makes a market of one happy and that is
you so I will close there and thanks to
everybody for listening hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday and
that provides a little morsel of fun for
the weekend and five bullet Friday is a
very short email where I share the
coolest things I've found or that I've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
comm that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business needs specifically in his
case to form his company but LegalZoom
isn't just for launching your business
their services include everything from
helping you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NBA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because Leal zoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up
and suspending circles just to raise
your bill instead they just ask you to
pay one low upfront price for whatever
it is that you're looking to get Alucard
style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but its
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take
peak legalzoom.com and enter promo code
Tim this episode is brought to you by
teeter I am so thrilled to have
connected with these guys because I've
used teeter products for many many years
I've traveled around the country and the
world with T different products and I'm
sitting about 15 feet in my home from
one of their inversion tables and we're
gonna talk more about all of that one of
my rituals is hanging and I should say
not really that it's maintenance and
performance program I hang not just in
the morning potentially but particularly
after a day of bearing weight whether
that includes weight training in Jersey
Greg rec world record-holder insists on
this type of inversion therapy after
training or just wearing heavy backpack
around a few minutes goes a long way
towards better sleep in my case less
back pain neck pain leg pain it's not a
panacea obviously but inversion therapy
would uses gravity in your own
bodyweight decompress the spine or
relieve pressure on the discs and
surrounding nerves seems to help with a
whole slew of conditions and just as a
general maintenance program it's one of
my favorite things to do so what to say
about that Peter why Teeter Teeter is
the best known name in inversion table
since 1981 more than 3 million people
have put their trust in Teeter Teeter is
also the only inversion table brand that
has been both safety certified by
Underwriters Laboratories at the UL few
people in
that industry will recognize it and
registered with the FDA as a class 1
medical device and they're giving a very
special offer just to you guys my
listeners for a limited time you can get
the teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories which I have a bunch of
again in the room next to me and a free
pair of gravity boots so that you can
invert at home or take the boots with
you to the gym so these gravity boots I
have three separate pairs of gravity
boots bought with my own money in three
different cities that I've had for a
very very long time because I don't want
to travel with them necessarily they
look kind of like ski boots but without
the foot portion and they hook you
upside down so you can take them really
anywhere you want to go to get this deal
which is a savings of over a hundred and
forty eight dollars it's very specific
so maybe 249 you have to go to Teeter
calm forward-slash Tim that's teeter
calm phone touched mt e ET ER you'll see
a free shipping a 60 day money back
guarantee and free returns so why not
try it out remember you can only get the
teeter inversion table with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots by going to Teeter comm forward
slash Tim so if you think of yourself
what the hell is this thing these talk
about I can't even envision it in my
head well take a look at the photos go
to teeter comp forward slash Tim
[Applause]